Hi, I'm Will, I generally go shampoo and then soap. Huh. I'm talking for showering. No, no, we got a guy. Sean, what's your loop? I go soap first always and then shampoo. Really? Huh.
嗨，我是威尔，我通常先洗头，然后用肥皂。哈。我说的是洗澡。不，不，我们这儿有个人。肖恩，你的流程是什么？我总是先用肥皂，然后洗头。真的吗？哈。
I go borrow soap and then I only wash this hair every four or five days. You don't have to say that out loud. But you know, if you wash your hair it gets too fluffy. You guys use moisturizer in your skin? When you get out, you guys use moisturizer? Yeah, I have a whole thing that I go through. This is no fluke. So you look like that after all this care, too?
我先用肥皂，然后每四五天洗一次头。你没必要大声说出来。但你知道，如果你洗头太勤，头发会变得太蓬松。你们平时用润肤霜吗？洗完澡出来，你们用润肤霜吗？是的，我有一整套流程。这不是偶然的。所以你做了这么多护理，看起来还是这样？
You need more care. That's so depressing. Why don't you cheer me up with a fresh episode of SmartLess? Okay, yeah, let's go. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
你需要更多的护理。那太令人沮丧了。你为什么不给我放一集新鲜的《SmartLess》让我开心一下呢？好的，没问题，我们开始吧。《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. Listener, Sean's got a little cap on and he's got his little glasses on.
《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。听众朋友们，肖恩戴着一顶小帽子，还戴着他的小眼镜。
He's the most positive, sweetest, nicest guy I think I've ever met in my life. Will, would you agree? Would you agree? I would agree. Do you feel warm and fuzzy when you're around, Sean? I feel warm and fuzzy when I'm around you, too. I love hanging out with you. I love Sean.
他是我这辈子见过的最积极、最贴心、最好的人。威尔，你同意吗？你同意吗？我同意。肖恩，你在身边的时候，你会感到温暖和亲切吗？我在你身边时也感到温暖和亲切。我喜欢和你在一起。我喜欢肖恩。
I'd like to hug because we're going to see each other tonight. Tonight. And I can't wait. We're going to see each other and we're going to hold each other for a long time. Jason's been away. So he's missed the last couple. Because Sean, we've done it a few times the last week, couple weeks we've hung out and Jason hasn't been there.
我想拥抱一下，因为我们今晚要见面。今晚。我等不及了。我们要见面，还要紧紧拥抱很长时间。杰森出差了。所以他错过了最近的几次聚会。因为肖恩，过去几周我们聚了几次，杰森都不在。
Jason, I know you were finishing up. But by the way, we haven't said, yeah, we haven't said you completely wrapped Ozark. Yeah. Congratulations. Finished Ozark. Thank you very much. How do you feel? Congratulations.
杰森，我知道你在忙着收尾。顺便说一下，我们还没说呢，是的，我们还没说你已经完全拍完《黑钱胜地》了。是的。恭喜你。拍完《黑钱胜地》了。非常感谢。你感觉如何？恭喜。
I feel, you know, obviously a little sad that I'm not going to see those people as much anymore. Name one of them. Quickly, name one of them. Name one of those people. Linda Linney. She was an incredible Laura. It's Laura.
我感觉，你知道，显然有点难过，因为我以后见不到那些人了。说出一个人的名字。快，说出一个人的名字。说出那些人中的一个。琳达·琳妮。她是一位了不起的劳拉。是劳拉。
It's Laura. What is it? Laura Linney, dude. Oh, Jesus Christ. Five years have been gone. Why does she never correct me? How about that? Linda Linney.
是劳拉。是什么？劳拉·琳妮，伙计。哦，天哪。五年过去了。为什么她从来不纠正我？那又怎么样？琳达·琳妮。
But I feel like the audience is going to really dig this last season. That's great. We've stitched it all up. Well, I love that. It's made a lot of people really entertained. Sad and scared. No, but do you feel, what is that feeling you feel right now? Is it you feel probably relief to a certain degree and also maybe you haven't processed
但我感觉观众会非常喜欢这一季。那太棒了。我们把它圆满收尾了。嗯，我喜欢这样。它让很多人感到非常有趣。悲伤和恐惧。不，但你感觉，你现在是什么感觉？是某种程度上的解脱，还是说你还没消化
all of the, I don't know. I'm speaking for you. Probably. Yeah, probably. Probably stuff will hit me later on, but I do the overwhelming feeling I have is a little bit of relief and some pride that we all didn't screw it up. I don't think, you know, because a lot of people don't know, a lot of people don't know Jay that you shot the final two seasons and now there's no more like there's, there is
所有的，我不知道。我在替你说话。可能吧。是的，可能吧。可能过会儿那种感觉才会涌上来，但我现在最强烈的感受是有一点解脱，还有一点自豪，因为我们大家没有搞砸它。我不认为，你知道，因为很多人不知道，很多人不知道杰伊你拍完了最后两季，现在没有了，就是，有
no more. Yeah. And I feel like we, I hope that we didn't screw it up. There was, there was a chance that we, that we will let you know. Yeah. You'll let me know. Keep your phone on. Thank you.
没有了。是的。我觉得我们，我希望我们没有搞砸。有，有可能会让我们知道。是的。你会让我知道的。保持手机开机。谢谢。
You're very honest that way, Sean. I like that about you. Thank you. Jason, Jason, how are you? Well, you feel dumb four years from now when you're like, I can't believe I'm shooting return to Ozark for, for, you know, the new streaming service. That's from Ozark also. Yeah.
肖恩，你在这方面非常诚实。我喜欢你这一点。谢谢。杰森，杰森，你怎么样？好吧，四年后你会觉得自己很蠢，当你心想，我不敢相信我正在为，你知道，新的流媒体服务拍摄《重返黑钱胜地》。那也是《黑钱胜地》的。是的。
The new Jack in the Box streaming service, you know. Ozark too. T double O. Just like the wolf. All right. Let's get right to it. Listen guys. We all, listen, listen to how written this is.
新的Jack in the Box流媒体服务，你知道的。《黑钱胜地》2。T-O-O。就像那只狼一样。好了。我们直接进入正题吧。听着，伙计们。我们都，听听这写得有多正式。
We all go to the doctor at some point in our lives to feel better, right? Wait, we're not doing hypochondriac. No, we aren't. Hypochondriac is my other podcast. I do know. We're not doing that. Find it where you find your podcasts. That's right.
我们一生中总会在某个时刻去看医生以求感觉好点，对吧？等等，我们不是在做《疑病症》节目。不，我们不是。疑病症是我的另一个播客。我知道。我们不是在做那个。在你能找到播客的地方就能找到它。没错。
But today we have the doctor of all doctors who's going to make us all feel a little better. I'm super excited to meet him and ask him a bunch of dumb questions because I know nothing. I don't even understand his title, to be honest. So that'll be my first question. But who's this doctor fellow? He's one of the smartest people on the planet. He got his MD from Yale. He is among the most trusted voices in America on matters of public health.
但今天我们请到了医生中的医生，他会让大家都感觉好一点。我非常兴奋能见到他，并问他一堆愚蠢的问题，因为我什么都不知道。老实说，我甚至不明白他的头衔。所以那将是我的第一个问题。但这位医生是谁呢？他是地球上最聪明的人之一。他在耶鲁大学获得了医学博士学位。他是美国公共卫生事务中最受信任的声音之一。
He's the nation's doctor. He is the United States surgeon general. What? What's Dr. Vivek H. Murthy. What? Good Lord. Hello guys. There he is.
他是国家的医生。他是美国卫生局局长。什么？什么？维韦克·H·默西医生。什么？天哪。你们好。他就在那儿。
Wow. What an honor. Look at you. Look at this guy. Sean, you have outdone it here. By the way, you look like, I know you get this every day. You look like you're 19 years old. Well, I'll take that as a compliment.
哇。真是荣幸。看看你。看看这家伙。肖恩，你这次做得太棒了。顺便说一下，你看上去，我知道你每天都听到这个。你看上去就像19岁。好吧，我就把它当作赞美了。
Thank you, Sean. Yeah. How old a fellow are you? Well, I'm 44 years old. Oh my God. How can you be 44? You've done so much more with your life, Admiral, than I have at 51. It's embarrassing.
谢谢，肖恩。是的。你多大年纪了？嗯，我44岁了。哦，天哪。你怎么可能才44岁？海军上将，你的人生经历比我51岁时丰富多了。真令人尴尬。
Surgeon general at 44. But this is, I want to say this is the second time? No. Yes. Yes. And you're at the 19th, is that correct? He's surprised you knew anything. Did you hear that?
44岁的卫生局局长。但这，我想说这是第二次？不。是的。是的。你现在是第19任，对吗？他很惊讶你居然知道这些。你听到了吗？
No. Sorry. I don't mean to misquote you. Yeah, no. I was the 19th Surgeon General under President Obama. Back during his second term. And yeah, now I serve as the 21st Surgeon General. 21st, right.
不。抱歉。我不是故意引用错误的。是的，不。我是奥巴马总统任内的第19任卫生局局长。在他第二个任期期间。是的，现在我担任第21任卫生局局长。第21任，对吧。
Sir, if I may. Now, how do we address you? Admiral is okay? That's okay? Well, so, Will, I'm actually incredibly impressed that you know this. Okay. Because most people assume that I'm, that general is my title. But technically, I'm an Admiral, actually.
长官，请允许我问一下。我们该怎么称呼您？叫海军上将可以吗？可以吗？嗯，威尔，我其实对你知道这一点感到非常惊讶。好吧。因为大多数人都以为“将军”是我的头衔。但从技术上讲，我其实是一位海军上将。
Wow. But how did you know that? Most people? You know, I guessed. And can you look like you had an Admiral quality to you? He's got a fast internet signal. Well, how did you know that, Will? I've got real fast broadband here.
哇。但你是怎么知道的？大多数人？你知道，我猜的。而且你看上去确实有一种海军上将的气质。他的宽带网速很快。好吧，威尔，你是怎么知道的？我这儿的宽带网速很快。
Yeah. Now, let me ask a dumb question. Admiral is Navy? Yeah, so great question. Thank you. You didn't graduate high school? So Admiral is Navy, yes? So Admiral is Navy, but there are also other services that have the title Admiral or the
是的。现在，让我问个愚蠢的问题。海军上将是海军的？是的，好问题。谢谢。你没从高中毕业吗？所以海军上将是海军的，对吧？所以海军上将是海军的，但也有其他部门拥有海军上将的头衔或
rank system that includes Admiral and one of them. So we have eight uniformed services in the U.S. government, the Army, Navy, Air Force you're familiar with. One of them is also the United States Public Health Service Commission Corps. And that's the service of which I serve as a commanding officer. We have about 6,000 nurses, doctors, pharmacists, physical therapists, and we deploy them around the country during times of emergency. You know, Ebola back in the day, hurricanes, tornadoes, and now COVID-19.
包括海军上将在内的军衔体系，其中之一就是。所以我们美国政府有八个制服部门，陆军、海军、空军你很熟悉。其中之一也是美国公共卫生服务军官团。那是我担任指挥官的部门。我们大约有6000名护士、医生、药剂师、物理治疗师，我们在紧急情况下将他们部署到全国各地。你知道，当年的埃博拉病毒，飓风，龙卷风，现在是新冠肺炎。
And so in the public health service, we used a similar rank system as the Navy. So Admiral is equivalent, our equivalent of general in the Army or Air Force. Wow. Congratulations. Again, I'm sorry. What is that department that is uniform that goes out? So it's the United States Public Health Service Commission Corps. Okay.
所以在公共卫生服务中，我们使用了与海军类似的军衔体系。所以海军上将相当于我们在陆军或空军中的将军。哇。恭喜。再次抱歉。那个制服部门叫什么名字？是美国公共卫生服务军官团。好的。
Wow, amazing. And so you said there are doctors and there are pharmacists. Yes. Yes. Doctors, nurses, physical therapists, pharmacists, public health engineers. Wow. Most people don't even know they exist. So you could, so in the middle of an emergency, your doorbell could ring as like, hey, listen,
哇，太神奇了。你说有医生，还有药剂师。是的。是的。医生、护士、物理治疗师、药剂师、公共卫生工程师。哇。大多数人甚至不知道他们的存在。所以，在紧急情况下，你的门铃可能会响，就像，嘿，听着，
we got a massage coming your way. I'm a physical therapist and I've been ordered to give you a massage. Sure. But we haven't built out that capacity yet for the, the massage needs. But let me just tell you, my relaxation is critical to the security of this nation. Yeah, right. Now, Admiral, where do we, where do we find you today? Are you in Los Angeles?
我们派了一个按摩师过来。我是物理治疗师，我接到命令来给你按摩。当然。但我们还没有为按摩需求建立那种能力。但让我告诉你，我的放松对这个国家的安全至关重要。是的，没错。现在，海军上将，我们今天在哪里能找到您？您在洛杉矶吗？
You're not in Los Angeles. You're in Washington, D.C., I'll bet. Yes? I am. Yeah, I'm in Washington, D.C. And a typical day for you is where is the, where is the office? It's not, it's not the White House, is it? So I split my, when I'm in D.C. itself, I split my time between the White House and
你不在洛杉矶。我敢打赌你在华盛顿特区。对吗？是的。我在。是的，我在华盛顿特区。你典型的一天，办公室在哪里？不是白宫，对吧？所以当我身处华盛顿特区时，我的时间分配在白宫和
the Department of Health and Human Services, which is by the Congress building. And, you know, we spend a lot of time also just, there's no actual typical day because some days were, like yesterday, for example, I was visiting a middle school in Washington, D.C. and doing sort of a virtual town hall with middle schoolers around the country for a get to know your classmate day, which is actually a sort of a national designation, which most people don't know about, but which is sort of a fun day to focus on social connection and community in schools. And other days, you know, I'm, I'm doing sort of press, you know, related engagements
卫生与公众服务部之间，就在国会大厦旁边。而且，你知道，我们也花很多时间，其实没有典型的日子，因为有些日子，比如昨天，我访问了华盛顿特区的一所中学，并与全国的中学生进行了一场虚拟市政厅会议，为了“了解你的同学日”，这实际上是一种国家指定的日子，大多数人不知道，但这是一个关注学校社交联系和社区的有趣日子。其他日子，你知道，我在做一些媒体相关的活动
where they, you know, connected to COVID-19. And other days I'm working on our commission core and getting our officers deployed to emergency. So every day is incredibly different. And we, we feel a lot of incoming inquiries from the public, you know, people will, a lot of people have questions about COVID-19, about their schools and how they can keep their kids safe. But a lot of people have non-COVID questions too.
与新冠肺炎有关的。其他日子我在处理我们的军官团，并让我们的军官部署到紧急情况中。所以每一天都非常不同。我们，我们收到了很多公众的询问，你知道，很多人对新冠肺炎、学校以及如何保护孩子安全有疑问。但很多人也有非新冠的问题。
People sometimes send us their own personal medical question. It's pretty extraordinary. How did this come your way? How did, how did you receive a request from Sean P. Hayes? Why did you say yes? How did this, how did this look through? You know, let me, let me just start out by saying, because I like, I don't want to speak for most people, but I'm an idiot.
人们有时会给我们发送他们个人的医疗问题。这太不寻常了。你是怎么接到这个邀请的？你是怎么收到肖恩·P·海耶斯的请求的？你为什么答应了？这，这看起来怎么样？你知道，让我，让我先说一下，因为我，我不想代表大多数人，但我是个白痴。
And I, I really don't understand what it is you do. And I'm fascinated. I mean, I know a little bit, but I'm fascinated in what Jason just said. What's the day in the life of someone in your position? And how do you delegate? How do you manage what's going on? And then deploy the help to that's needed, you know, all of those kinds of things. Yeah. Well, it's, well, I'll answer both of your questions.
而且我，我真的不明白你是做什么的。我很着迷。我的意思是，我知道一点，但我对杰森刚才说的话很着迷。你这个职位的人的一天是怎样的？你如何授权？你如何管理正在发生的事情？然后部署所需的帮助，你知道，所有这些事情。是的。好吧，我会回答你们两个的问题。
That's why I asked you to come on. So I could learn. Yeah. No, and I, and I appreciate it. And I'll tell you when my, when my team told me about the invitation from you, Sean, and from your team. And I actually, I was excited to do this because. They had to show you a photo of Sean, like this is the guy. Still is not ringing any bells.
这就是我请你来的原因。这样我就可以学习了。是的。不，而且我，我很感激。我会告诉你，当我的团队告诉我你的邀请时，肖恩，还有你的团队。我其实很兴奋能做这件事，因为。他们不得不给你看一张肖恩的照片，就像这就是那个人。还是没印象。
Promises, promises. That's it. Well, I'll tell you most of the engagements to do are pretty darn serious. I thought it would be fun to actually do something that was laid back where we could talk about important stuff that have fun while we do it. Yes, for sure. I have one question that I, this is a burning question and which is this, when I go to school as a four year old, when I first, or sorry,
承诺，承诺。就是这样。好吧，我会告诉你，大多数要做的活动都非常严肃。我想如果能做一些轻松的事情，我们可以谈论重要的事情，同时玩得开心，那会很有趣。是的，当然。我有一个问题，我，这是一个迫切的问题，就是这个，当我四岁上学时，当我第一次，或者抱歉，
when I first go to like first grade as a six year old, let's say, what are the, cause I remember going through this with my, with my two older boys. I'm going to have to do with my youngest son again and remind me what are the, what I have to prepare my, my son for, what he has to be inoculated against when he goes into school. Oh yeah. Great question. Well, there are a whole series of things that kids need to be inoculated for these days,
当我六岁第一次上一年级时，比如说，什么是，因为我记得我和我的两个大儿子经历过这个。我又要和我的小儿子再经历一次，提醒我，我必须为我的儿子准备什么，当他上学时他必须接种什么疫苗。哦，是的。好问题。嗯，现在孩子们需要接种一系列疫苗，
including measles, mumps, rubella, polio, and a series of others. And the good news is like this has been going on for a while. How long does like, like, like 50 hundred years, a lot of these more longer, right? Yeah. So it's interesting. Like if you look back in our history as a country, the first real requirement around vaccination around inoculations was actually George Washington, President George Washington, asking the troops actually to get inoculated against smallpox because more soldiers were
包括麻疹、腮腺炎、风疹、脊髓灰质炎和其他一系列疫苗。好消息是，这已经持续了一段时间了。持续了多久，像，像50年、100年，很多这些更久了，对吧？是的。所以很有趣。如果你回顾我们作为一个国家的历史，关于疫苗接种的第一个真正要求实际上是乔治·华盛顿，乔治·华盛顿总统，要求部队接种天花疫苗，因为更多的士兵
dying from smallpox than anyone would have imagined. And after that, though, in the 1800s will is when schools started to require various vaccinations and they just increase. So now the vast, vast majority of schools in America have these same requirements around vaccines. So most adults that I know that you and I know and encounter, whether they're friends or we're having dinner or we encounter them at the store or on the subway or in the parks or wherever we go, most of these adults.
死于天花，超乎任何人的想象。但在此之后，在19世纪，威尔，学校开始要求各种疫苗接种，而且它们一直在增加。所以现在美国绝大多数学校对疫苗都有这些相同的要求。所以大多数我认识的成年人，你和我认识和遇到的，无论是朋友，还是我们一起吃晚饭，或者我们在商店、地铁、公园或任何我们去的地方遇到他们，大多数这些成年人。
How about on a bus? On a bus or on a plane or on a bus. Or on a box or on a train or on a box or on a bus. Most of these people, like 99% of these people have been inoculated against all these things that you've just, they've received a vaccine against all these things that you just named. Is that true? If they wanted to go to school, they had to. I'm just asking about those things, measles and moms who rebelled those things, right?
在公共汽车上怎么样？在公共汽车上，或者飞机上，或者公共汽车上。或者在盒子上，或者火车上，或者盒子上，或者公共汽车上。大多数这些人，像99%的人，都接种了你刚才提到的所有这些疫苗，他们接种了你刚才提到的所有这些东西的疫苗。是真的吗？如果他们想上学，他们就必须接种。我只是问关于那些东西，麻疹、腮腺炎、风疹那些东西，对吧？
Yeah. If they went through the school system, they did. So if they went to school at all, then they did that. Okay. That's interesting. Okay. Good to know. So in some cases, you know, like there may have been exceptions of people were able
是的。如果他们通过了学校系统，他们就接种了。所以如果他们上过学，那么他们就接种了。好的。这很有趣。好的。很高兴知道。所以在某些情况下，你知道，可能有一些例外，人们能够
to sort of carve out, but the vast majority went through the system and got vaccinated. That's actually why that's frankly the only reason that we were able to get vaccination rates so high for things like measles and why we're able to contain it. And so everybody, and whether it doesn't matter what vocation you were in, if you're an athlete, you were a podcaster or whatever it is that you did. What if you're an airline pilot or something? Or an airline pilot too, sure. Like a logger.
设法避开，但绝大多数人通过了系统并接种了疫苗。这实际上就是，坦率地说，我们能够使麻疹等疾病的疫苗接种率如此之高，以及我们能够控制它的唯一原因。所以每个人，无论你从事什么职业，如果你是运动员，你是播客，或者无论你做什么。如果你是航空公司飞行员怎么办？或者航空公司飞行员也一样，当然。像伐木工。
Yeah, or a logger. Any of those things, any of those things I named, a logger, airline pilot. A gardener. You went to school, you got inoculated against those things, right? That's right. Thank you, doctor. That's very well. That's interesting.
是的，或者伐木工。任何这些事情，任何我提到的事情，伐木工，航空公司飞行员。园丁。你上过学，你接种了这些疫苗，对吧？没错。谢谢，医生。那很好。那很有趣。
A lawyer specializing in cross-examination. He'll box you in. I'm just asking about those things that we've historically done. That's it. So, sorry, Jason, I cut you off. You were going to ask a question about his day-to-day. No, I was done a full stop. I think Sean looks like he's got something right.
一位专门从事交叉询问的律师。他会把你逼到墙角。我只是问关于我们历史上做过的那些事情。就是这样。所以，抱歉，杰森，我打断你了。你刚才要问关于他日常工作的问题。不，我问完了，句号。我觉得肖恩看起来有什么话要说。
I have many questions. Here, let's have it. You're instrumental in preventing the spread of Ebola and Zika viruses. And tell us what it's like to get information like that on possibly deadly viruses and how you go about stopping them before they become pandemics. And by the way, have those been eradicated? I don't know. And what are the odds that they're coming back to three part?
我有很多问题。来吧，说吧。你在预防埃博拉和寨卡病毒的传播方面发挥了重要作用。告诉我们，获得关于可能致命病毒的信息是什么感觉，以及在它们成为大流行病之前，你是如何阻止它们的。顺便问一下，这些病毒被根除了吗？我不知道。它们卷土重来的几率是多少？三部分问题。
Yeah, well, great question. So there is still Ebola in the world. In fact, we are still working hard to identify and to control cases that have surfaced over recent months in Africa. And that's something we're going to have to continue to remain vigilant about. But to your broader question, like, how do you react when these things come in? Yeah, what do you do? There are always various threats that are running.
是的，好问题。所以世界上仍然有埃博拉病毒。事实上，我们仍在努力识别和控制近几个月在非洲出现病例。这是我们需要继续保持警惕的事情。但对于你更广泛的问题，比如，当这些事情发生时，你有什么反应？是的，你做什么？总是有各种威胁在运行。
We don't have the luxury of running, unfortunately. So what we've got to do, first of all, is very quickly understand what's known and what's not known. And the chuffed part about a lot of these epidemics and pandemics when they start is that you've got enough to know that you have to worry, but there's still a lot of open unanswered questions. COVID-19 perfect example, right? When it became clear that there's something that we really needed to worry about, you know, at the end of 2019, beginning of 2020, there was still a lot of open unanswered questions. And so it's this circumstance where you've got to move forward with incomplete information
不幸的是，我们没有逃避的奢侈。所以我们首先要做的是非常迅速地了解已知和未知的情况。很多这些流行病和大流行病开始时最棘手的部分是，你知道的足够多，知道你需要担心，但仍然有很多未解的问题。新冠肺炎就是一个完美的例子，对吧？当很明显这是我们需要真正担心的事情时，你知道，在2019年底，2020年初，仍然有很多未解的问题。所以这种情况是你必须在信息不完整的情况下前进，
but recognizing that if you wait to get all the answers to all your questions, it's going to be too late. A lot of damage could potentially be done. And that's the difference between sort of working sort of in a theoretical setting and working in applied medicine and science, which is what public health is all about. And so it's, you know, those are difficult times and you've got to quickly convene, you know, all of your scientific expertise in government, pull together people outside, government who are experts as well, and then make the best judgment and call you can about really a few things.
但要认识到，如果你等到得到所有问题的答案，那就太晚了。可能会造成很大的损害。这就是在理论环境中工作和在应用医学和科学中工作之间的区别，这就是公共卫生的全部意义所在。所以，你知道，那些是困难的时期，你必须迅速召集，你知道，你政府中所有的科学专业知识，召集政府外也是专家的专家，然后做出最好的判断，关于几件事。
One, how to communicate to the public about this so people know how alarmed they should be. But also what measures to take, like, you know, do you start rolling out precautions in hospitals? You ask people to take precautionary measures to reduce spread. So there's a lot of decisions that have to get figured out very, very quickly. You know, World War II, Admiral, World War II, they used to have this thing where when they were bombing, on both sides, when they were bombing, that people would turn off their lights, right? They'd institute a blackout so that the planes couldn't see. And there were a lot of people who were like, I don't want to turn my lights off
第一，如何向公众传达这一点，以便人们知道他们应该有多警惕。但也包括采取什么措施，比如，你知道，你是否开始在医院推出预防措施？你要求人们采取预防措施以减少传播。所以有很多决定必须非常非常快地弄清楚。你知道，二战，海军上将，二战，他们过去有一种做法，当他们轰炸时，双方，当他们轰炸时，人们会关掉灯，对吧？他们实行灯火管制，这样飞机就看不见。而且有很多人说，我不想关灯，
because I want to be free to keep my lights on. And it wasn't necessarily that your lights specifically were going to, then they were going to go, there's London because we see one guy's lights. But if everybody did that, then all the lights would be on. So it really counted on everybody keeping their lights off. And you know what? Most people did it because they didn't want to get bombed, right? Yeah.
因为我想自由地保持开灯。而且并不一定是因为你的灯特别会，然后他们就会去，那是伦敦，因为我们看到了一个人的灯。但如果每个人都这样做，那么所有的灯都会亮着。所以这确实取决于每个人都保持关灯。而且你知道吗？大多数人都这样做了，因为他们不想被炸，对吧？是的。
It seems kind of simple. Again, I'm not drawing any parallels. No, I feel like I'm picking up on some kind of a parallel. No, no, no, no, no. I'm just trying to remind myself I'm asking the doctor if that seems true for a lot of the things he's working with. Well, it's a really interesting point you bring up, Will, because it points to a historical tension we've had in our country, right? And not just us, but a lot of sort of modern nations and modern cultures, if you will,
这看起来很简单。再说一次，我不是在画任何平行线。不，我觉得我感觉到某种平行线。不，不，不，不，不。我只是想提醒自己，我是在问医生，这对于他正在处理的许多事情是否看起来是真的。嗯，这是一个非常有趣的观点，威尔，因为它指出了我们国家历史上存在的一种紧张关系，对吧？不仅是我们，还有许多现代国家和现代文化，如果你愿意的话，
which is there's a tension between the collective interest and the individual interest, right? We all want to have our individual choices and freedoms to make decisions for ourselves. But then there are circumstances where those decisions tend to affect other people. The classic example is driving on the freeway, right? Yeah. So we tell people you got to obey a speed limit because if you drive at 100 miles an hour, your decision potentially can affect somebody else. And so, you know, when it comes to things like, for example, you shared about turning your lights out,
那就是集体利益和个人利益之间存在紧张关系，对吧？我们都希望有我们的个人选择和自由来为自己做决定。但也有一些情况，这些决定往往会影响其他人。经典的例子是在高速公路上开车，对吧？是的。所以我们告诉人们你必须遵守限速，因为如果你以每小时100英里的速度行驶，你的决定可能会影响别人。所以，你知道，当涉及到像，例如，你分享的关灯的事情时，
everyone incrementally reduces risk, right? You know, when people can't see or plants can't see where a city is, and then they potentially won't vomit. But also when it comes to health, that is true in so many circumstances. So what you mentioned around schools and why we have vaccination requirements in schools, that was done in part because we recognize that if a child comes to school and they're sick, there's a chance that they could spread that to other people. Even if those other people are vaccinated, some small portion of people may not respond to vaccines.
每个人都在逐步降低风险，对吧？你知道，当人们看不见或飞机看不见城市在哪里时，它们可能就不会轰炸。但当涉及到健康时，在许多情况下也是如此。所以你提到的关于学校以及为什么我们在学校有疫苗接种要求，这在一定程度上是因为我们认识到，如果一个孩子生病来到学校，他们有可能将其传播给其他人。即使那些人接种了疫苗，一小部分人可能对疫苗没有反应。
The vaccines aren't 100%, even though a lot of them are really, really good. So it's a step that we take to really protect the common good, recognizing that we have shared interests. And that balance has always been a challenge for us as a country, something we have to negotiate often with every new set of decisions. Right. When you were starting to become a doctor, did you see yourself playing a role like this, or was your intention to be a much more sort of traditional medical doctor?
疫苗不是100%有效的，尽管其中许多真的非常好。所以这是我们采取的真正保护共同利益的步骤，认识到我们有共同的利益。这种平衡对我们作为一个国家来说一直是一个挑战，是我们经常必须通过每一套新决定来协商的事情。对。当你开始成为一名医生时，你是否看到自己扮演这样的角色，还是你的初衷是成为一名更传统的医生？
Yeah. How'd you get the job? Yeah. Yeah, it was absolutely not in my, sort of in my to-do list, dream list, you know, five-year plan. I'll tell you this, I actually never, I feel slightly embarrassed about this, but I never wanted to serve in government at all because I thought that government was one of the least efficient and effective ways to create change. That was my, my belief as a child, you know, growing up and just thinking about the world and what I wanted to do. It wasn't that I didn't think it was important, but it just didn't feel like it was like the right place for me.
是的。你是怎么得到这份工作的？是的。是的，这绝对不在我的，待办事项清单，梦想清单，五年计划中。我告诉你这个，我其实从来没有，我对此感到有点尴尬，但我从来不想在政府工作，因为我认为政府是创造变革效率最低和效果最差的方式之一。那是我的，我小时候的信念，你知道，成长过程中，只是思考世界以及我想做什么。并不是我不认为它很重要，但它只是感觉不像是适合我的地方。
So where I was focusing my time was I was, you know, I was practicing medicine, you know, I was training in medicine. I thought I was in a practice and I would maybe do other things like build nonprofit organizations. I had started with my sister doing a lot of HIV education work back in the 90s and we built our first nonprofit together. And I thought maybe I'd do stuff like that, you know, like sort of all, but all in the private sector. But what happened was actually kind of unexpected for me, which is that in 2007, 2008, you may remember like the presidential primaries on both sides were kind of getting up and going. Yeah. And there was a lot of discussion, you know, on both sides of the political aisle about healthcare.
所以我把时间集中在，我当时在，你知道，我在练习医学，你知道，我在接受医学培训。我以为我会在诊所工作，我可能会做其他事情，比如建立非营利组织。我在90年代和我的妹妹一起做了很多艾滋病教育工作，我们一起建立了我们的第一个非营利组织。我想也许我会做类似的事情，你知道，就像，但都在私营部门。但发生的事情对我来说其实有点出乎意料，那就是在2007年、2008年，你可能记得像两党的总统初选都在进行。是的。而且有很多讨论，你知道，在政治两党中关于医疗保健。
And one of the things I realized is that a lot of my colleagues in the hospital, they were getting to be pretty cynical and burned out and pessimistic because they felt that the system wasn't really working for patients or for healthcare providers, but it was primarily working for insurance companies. And so they were kind of feeling, frankly, pretty bummed out about this and not like and despondent and not so hopeful. And I just thought, hey, if this is a chance when there's a lot of discussion, maybe some real change could happen, maybe we should organize doctors around the country to have more of a voice advocating for patients to create a better healthcare system. So that's actually how I got into this world of advocacy and thinking about healthcare policy.
我意识到的一件事是，我在医院的许多同事，他们变得相当愤世嫉俗、精疲力竭和悲观，因为他们觉得系统并没有真正为患者或医疗保健提供者工作，而是主要为保险公司工作。所以他们感觉，坦率地说，对此相当沮丧，不像，而且绝望，而不是那么充满希望。我只是想，嘿，如果这是一个有很多讨论的机会，也许真正的改变可能会发生，也许我们应该组织全国的医生，让他们有更多的声音为患者辩护，以创造一个更好的医疗保健系统。所以这就是我进入这个倡导和思考医疗保健政策的世界的方式。
It wasn't because I had any expertise. I was probably the least qualified person to like build that kind of organization or movement at the time. But what I lacked in experience, I tried to make up for in interest, curiosity and passion. And just straight common sense about what we kind of need, right? Well, yeah. And then what I found, Jason, was that like there are a lot of people like frontline nurses, doctors, physical therapists who are seeing like what the problems weren't. They had a pretty good sense of some of the things we had to change, but they weren't at the table, right?
并不是因为我有任何专业知识。我当时可能是最没有资格建立那种组织或运动的人。但我缺乏经验，我试图用兴趣、好奇心和热情来弥补。还有关于我们需要什么的纯粹常识，对吧？嗯，是的。然后我发现，杰森，像有很多一线护士、医生、物理治疗师，他们看到了问题所在。他们对我们需要改变的一些事情有很好的感觉，但他们没有坐在谈判桌前，对吧？
When decisions were being made about what policies to put in place. So I started doing some of that work. But even with all of that, I didn't think I was going to do anything in government. Then finally it happened. Actually, I was coming back from LA actually to Boston. I went out on a red-eye flight and I got off the plane and I was like ready to go home and just like, you know, crash in bed because I can't sleep on flights. And I remembered I had left my dry cleaning, you know, the dry cleaning place. I was like, oh, God, it's been sitting there for days.
当决定实施什么政策时。所以我开始做一些那样的工作。但即使有所有这些，我也不认为我会在政府做任何事情。最后它发生了。其实，我当时正从洛杉矶回到波士顿。我坐了一趟红眼航班，我下了飞机，我准备回家，就像，你知道，倒在床上，因为我在飞机上睡不着。我记得我把干洗的东西留在了干洗店。我想，哦，天哪，它已经在那里放了好几天了。
Let me just go get it. So I go pick up my dry clean. My hands are full, right? And my phone rings. And I happened to glance at it and it's a 202 number, which is Washington, DC. I didn't recognize the number. So I'm like, I'm not going to pick it up. Let me just keep going.
让我去拿吧。所以我去拿我的干洗衣服。我的手满了，对吧？我的电话响了。我碰巧瞥了一眼，那是202区号，也就是华盛顿特区。我不认识这个号码。所以我心想，我不接了。让我继续走吧。
Keeps ringing, keeps ringing. Finally, if something comes, you just pick it up. So I pick up the phone and it turns out that call was actually called from the White House to ask me if I would be interested in being considered to serve a surgeon general. And I was like, this is so out of the blue. Where is this coming from? And you put it in your spam folder. You put that number back in the spam. Don't ever call me again.
一直响，一直响。最后，如果有什么事，你只是接听。所以我接了电话，结果那个电话其实是白宫打来的，问我是否有兴趣考虑担任卫生局局长。我当时想，这太突然了。这是从哪儿来的？你把它放进垃圾邮件文件夹了。你把那个号码放回垃圾邮件里。别再给我打电话了。
You know what I did is I actually, I called my then-girlfriend, that wife, Alice. And I said, Alice, who was in LA at the time she lived there? And she said, Alice, I just got the weirdest call. You'll never, ever guess like who this was. She was like, was it the White House asking you to be a surgeon general? I was like, whoa, how did you know this? This is like crazy. Where did that come from?
你知道我做了什么，我其实，我给当时的女朋友，现在的妻子，爱丽丝打了电话。我说，爱丽丝，当时她在洛杉矶，她住在那里？我说，爱丽丝，我刚接到一个最奇怪的电话。你永远，永远猜不到这是谁。她说，是白宫让你当卫生局局长吗？我说，哇，你怎么知道的？这太疯狂了。那是从哪儿来的？
She's like, I don't know. I just had this intuition. So that's how I actually ended up coming down this path. But I'll tell you the last thing that, and this is the part that I never could have figured out. Wait, did she put you up for the job? Is that what happened? No, she didn't actually. In fact, she was far more loved by people in the administration than I was.
她说，我不知道。我只是有这种直觉。所以这就是我最终走上这条道路的方式。但我会告诉你最后一件事，这是我永远无法弄清楚的部分。等等，是她让你去申请这份工作的吗？是这样吗？不，她其实没有。事实上，她比我更受政府里的人喜爱。
She said, if you guys met her, if she was on this podcast, you'd understand why I'm like about 30 seconds. A lot more likable. And she's just awesome. Yeah. Cause you're a nightmare. You're not likable at all, you're super smart and kind and very sweet. Yeah, terrible. But I'll tell you, the thing I never could have predicted is up until then I had lived a pretty hodgepodge life.
她说，如果你们见过她，如果她在这个播客上，你们就会明白为什么我像大约30秒。更讨人喜欢。而且她太棒了。是的，因为你是个噩梦。你一点也不讨人喜欢，你超级聪明、善良而且非常贴心。是的，太糟糕了。但我会告诉你，我永远无法预测的事情是，在那之前我过着相当杂乱的生活。
Like I had been building these nonprofits. I had like started the tech company. I was practicing medicine as teaching and none of them really seemed like they fit together. Right? There was like people would sometimes look at my resume and be like, you can't make up your mind, which you want to do. That seems to be your problem. Right. So the thing is, in the job as Surgeon General, I find that all of those elements actually came together.
就像我一直在建立这些非营利组织。我像创办了科技公司。我在练习医学，在教学，它们看起来都不太合适。对吧？就像人们有时会看我的简历，然后说，你不能决定你想做什么。那似乎是你的问题。对。所以问题是，在担任卫生局局长的工作中，我发现所有这些元素其实都结合在一起了。
You know, President Obama at the time and his team really wanted to modernize the role of Surgeon General. They wanted to think about, it was just in the middle of the Ebola crisis when I came in. But they wanted to really think about how that office could be effective, you know, as a public health educator using modern day tools. I found that all of the experience I had built in my sort of tech company days where I was doing a lot of like the UI UX work, you know, in terms of like the front end, you know, the sites we were building, that came in handy. The grassroots organizing I had done and building our advocacy organization came in handy to build our public health campaigns. Like all of the clinical medicine work, of course, came in handy. My basic research background came in handy.
你知道，当时的奥巴马总统和他的团队真的想使卫生局局长的角色现代化。他们想思考，我进来时正处于埃博拉危机的中间。但他们想真正思考那个办公室如何能有效，你知道，作为一名公共卫生教育者，使用现代工具。我发现我在科技公司时代积累的所有经验，我在那里做了很多UI UX工作，你知道，在前端方面，你知道，我们建立的网站，这派上了用场。我所做的草根组织和建立我们的倡导组织在建立我们的公共卫生运动时派上了用场。就像所有的临床医学工作，当然派上了用场。我的基础研究背景派上了用场。
So it was a funny way. It was that job that brought together all of these crazy disparate parts of my experience. And now back to the show. Let me ask you something because, you know, I have a bunch of really depressing questions to ask you. So we'll get to those in a minute. Great, can't wait. But what is the difference between- Warn our listeners so they can go fix themselves a beverage.
所以这是一种有趣的方式。正是那份工作将我所有这些疯狂的、不同的经验部分结合在了一起。现在回到节目。让我问你一件事，因为，你知道，我有一堆非常令人沮丧的问题要问你。所以我们一会儿再谈那些。太好了，等不及了。但有什么区别——警告我们的听众，这样他们就可以去给自己准备一杯饮料。
So what about, what's the difference between you and Fauci? Because Fauci gets all the airtime and he seems to be the voice of, has been the voice of this pandemic and all that's been going on with it. When it's you that probably is just speaking of job titles above him, correct? And having to implement all these things. Well, there are different institutions, first of all. Oh, I didn't know. See, I don't know this. Fauci is at the National Institute of Health, right?
那么，你和福奇之间有什么区别？因为福奇得到了所有的播出时间，他似乎是这个大流行病的声音，以及所有正在发生的事情的声音。而你才是那个职位头衔可能在他之上的人，对吧？并且必须实施所有这些事情。嗯，首先，有不同的机构。哦，我不知道。看，我不知道这个。福奇在国家卫生研究院，对吧？
That broadband connection is really working for you. You saw, I'm not even looking at that. I mean, I just happen to pay attention to stuff and I have to be what they call naturally smart. Go ahead. No, but I'm naturally stupid. But truly, I didn't know where, see, I don't know how that works. Like, isn't the surgeon general the top top? Like, that's the guy who runs the whole ship.
那个宽带连接真的对你很有用。你看，我甚至没看那个。我的意思是，我只是碰巧关注事情，而且我必须是他们所说的天生聪明。继续。不，但我天生愚蠢。但真的，我不知道在哪里，看，我不知道那是怎么运作的。就像，卫生局局长不是最高最高吗？就像，那是运行整个船的人。
Well, so it's a good question. So, and Tony Fauci is an extraordinary guy. He's a friend of mine from before we worked together when I was first SG, first time around and we work really closely now. So there are a number of people actually who sort of work as part of what is I think about a medical leadership team. And they sort of work in parallel, but also collaboratively. One is Tony Fauci, who's at the NIH and runs the National Institute for Allergy and Infectious Disease. He's been a leader really since HIV on every major infectious disease outbreak we've had. The other is the CDC director.
嗯，所以这是一个好问题。所以，托尼·福奇是一个非凡的人。他是我第一次担任SG时认识的朋友，我们现在工作非常密切。所以实际上有很多人作为我认为是医疗领导团队的一部分工作。他们以平行的方式工作，但也协作。一个是托尼·福奇，他在NIH，负责国家过敏和传染病研究所。他确实从艾滋病开始就是我们经历过的每一次重大传染病爆发的领导者。另一个是CDC主任。
The other is myself, you know, a surgeon general. And we all have sort of different lanes and there are a few others as well that we all have different lanes that we sort of occupy. So the CDC is putting out actual guidance, you know, based on the epidemiological research that they are conducting and data they're gathering. Tony Fauci and his team are focused a lot on research and sort of basic science questions around the vaccine, around some of the therapies or treatments that you can get, oral treatments and others. Myself, I focus a lot on everything from mobilizing our commission for to respond and support localities and states to doing a lot of public communications. So we do a lot of shared work together when it comes to decision making and we certainly split up a lot of the communications work. And actually, frankly, I'm grateful for that because this is like too big and too complicated a crisis for like one person to try to figure out entirely on their own. That's what I was going to ask you about.
另一个是我，你知道，卫生局局长。我们都有不同的轨道，还有其他一些人，我们都有不同的轨道。所以CDC正在发布实际的指导，你知道，基于他们正在进行的流行病学研究和他们正在收集的数据。托尼·福奇和他的团队专注于研究和关于疫苗、关于你可以获得的一些疗法或治疗、口服治疗和其他方面的基础科学问题。我自己，我专注于从动员我们的军官团来响应和支持地方和州，到做大量的公共传播。所以当涉及到决策时，我们一起做了很多共享工作，我们当然分担了很多传播工作。而且，坦率地说，我很感激这一点，因为这对于一个人来说太大了，太复杂了，无法完全靠自己弄清楚。这就是我要问你的。
Was it the rollout of all the vaccines, all the shots you guys had to move across the country and make sure that they were in all the CVSs and Walgreens and all that stuff. I mean, I'm sure you didn't get into the weeds, weeds, weeds on that, but I'm sure you were privy to some of those emails and the apparatus that you guys had to prop up in a week to try to get it out there and catch up for all of the horrifically wasted time. Was that an immense thing to oversee, to witness, to affect? I'm sure you'll be humble and say that you left it up to a lot of other folks, but that must have been overwhelming to accomplish, which you guys did remarkably well. Well, that's kind of adjacent. I mean, you're right that the logistics are just, I mean, it's absolutely extraordinary how complicated they are. Because even if you just take something as simple as getting vaccines to a pharmacy, right? There are different types of vaccines. They require different storages. They have different dosages. You, in some cases, have to advise patients differently on them because some are two doses, some are only one dose. It comes to getting them into doctor's offices. That's a whole other kettle of fish, right? Because doctor's offices have very different setups than pharmacies. They don't necessarily have big, deep, you know, deep freeze, you know, like, you know, apparatus like store, like in the Pfizer vaccine, which is required early on. So it's incredibly complicated and not to mention that each state often wants to approach it a bit differently, how they distribute the vaccines, how much they lean in or lean out, whether they want to do big, large mass vaccination events or a whole bunch of mobile units. So what we had to do early on as a federal government is really coordinate and support them with everything from funds to logistics to personnel and with metrics.
是关于所有疫苗的推广吗？你们必须在全国范围内调配所有这些针剂，并确保它们被送到所有的CVS和Walgreens药店等等。我的意思是，我肯定你没有陷入那些琐碎的细节中，但我相信你一定看过其中一些邮件，以及你们在一周内必须建立起来的机制，试图把疫苗分发出去，并弥补所有被可怕地浪费掉的时间。监督、见证并影响这一切是一项巨大的工程吗？我相信你会谦虚地说你把这些留给了其他人去处理，但这完成起来一定让人感到不知所措，而你们做得非常出色。嗯，这有点相关。我的意思是，你说得对，物流方面，我的意思是，它们有多复杂简直是不可思议。因为即使你只拿把疫苗送到药店这样简单的事情来说，对吧？疫苗有不同的类型。它们需要不同的储存条件。它们有不同的剂量。在某些情况下，你必须对患者提供不同的建议，因为有些是两剂，有些只有一剂。说到把它们送到医生办公室，那是另一码事了，对吧？因为医生办公室的设施与药店非常不同。他们不一定有大型的、深度的，你知道，深冻设备，你知道，像辉瑞疫苗早期所要求的那种。所以这极其复杂，更不用说每个州通常都希望以稍微不同的方式来处理疫苗的分发，他们投入的程度，以及他们是想举办大型的疫苗接种活动，还是使用大量的移动接种车。所以我们作为联邦政府在早期必须做的是，真正协调并支持他们，从资金到物流，再到人员和指标。
So we had to be able to quickly measure, like, how we're doing in each state because you don't want to wait three months to figure out something's not going well, right? You need to know AKSAP so you can fix it. So I'll say from our standpoint, like, you know, while I was not, like, you know, calling each of the CVS's and saying, hey, you know, got the vaccine, we had, thankfully, a team, sort of a COVID-19 team that had some really talented, capable people who were working on logistics. And every morning we would talk and talk through everything from what's the latest on the science, what's the latest on logistics and distribution on public education efforts, and we would go through all of that because, you know, every day so much happened and so much changed. I would imagine that without getting political, but given the last administration, you having already been the Surgeon General and watching what was happening slash not happening with that administration, did you hit redial on that phone number and say, hey, guys, if you're still interested, I'd still love to serve again because I see that there's there's a bit of a hole there or was it where you or did they call you? Were you super excited about that? That must have just been a really fraught time for you observing and being on the sideline and wanting to get back in there. It was a really complicated and frustrating year in 2020 for me because, you know, when you've been a part of pandemic responses before and you see, you know, the next pandemic come up, like, you just, and this is not a political statement, it's just a practical Samuel, you want to help, you know, you want to be involved, you want to serve in whatever way you can. Yeah, how frustrating is it when when what you want to do that you're you're involved in public health and serving and trying and looking out for the best interest of the public health. Any time, Paul, and again, all of us want to stay out of politics. When anytime is somebody is sort of inserts that it's like, no, no, no, I'm not here to serve a political agenda. I am. And you must, you must feel going crazy. You have to keep repeating that in different ways of explaining people.
所以我们必须能够快速衡量，比如，我们在每个州做得怎么样，因为你不想等三个月才发现事情进展不顺利，对吧？你需要尽快知道，这样你才能修复它。所以我会说从我们的立场来看，虽然我并没有，你知道，给每一家CVS打电话说，嘿，你们有疫苗了吗，但谢天谢地，我们有一个团队，一个COVID-19团队，里面有一些非常有才华、有能力的人在负责物流。每天早上我们都会交谈，讨论从科学上的最新进展，到物流和分发的最新情况，再到公共教育工作，我们会过一遍所有这些，因为每天发生的事情太多，变化也太多。我想象一下，不谈政治，但考虑到上一届政府，你已经担任过卫生局局长，并且看着那届政府正在发生或没有发生的事情，你有没有拨回那个电话号码说，嘿，伙计们，如果你们还有兴趣，我还是很乐意再次服务，因为我看到那里有一点空缺，还是他们给你打的电话？你对此感到非常兴奋吗？当你观察并站在场边，想要重新加入时，那对你来说一定是一个非常令人焦虑的时刻。2020年对我来说确实是一个非常复杂和令人沮丧的一年，因为当你之前参与过大流行应对工作，看到下一次大流行来临时，你只是，这不是政治声明，这只是一个实际的萨缪尔，你想帮忙，你想参与，你想以任何你能做的方式服务。是的，当你想要做的事情，你参与公共卫生并服务，试图照顾公共卫生的最大利益时，这有多令人沮丧？保罗，任何时候，再次重申，我们所有人都想远离政治。当有人插入说，不，不，不，我不是来服务政治议程的。我是。你一定，你一定觉得快疯了。你必须不断地用不同的方式重复这一点来向人们解释。
I'm not here to sell you anything. I'm trying to make you feel better. And I want everybody to be healthy. That's it. And there's a blueprint that we spent time working on and left behind and then it gets ignored. And then so you must have been like, please call, please call, please call. And then they did. Well, so this is actually what happened is in, or very early in the pandemic, early in 2020, you know, I had, I had worked a bit with then Vice President Biden and the mom administration, but he and his team had reached out to see if I could help just provide some support and advice during the early stages of COVID. You know, he and, and so I did, you know, in my general philosophy was look, if, if a decision maker, policymaker wants to understand more about a health related subject, as an expert, we should help. That's our job. You know, we need to like, that's what we should do for the public interest. But I also had known him from before and I knew that, you know, they, you know, he's very thoughtful about science expertise, like letting, you know, really leading with that first and foremost. And so I was like, yeah, you know, happy, happy to help. So what happened actually very in starting in March of 2020 is I his team asked me and one other colleague to start doing a series of daily briefings with him on COVID-19. And so it was a fascinating experience because, well, I had spent some time with him before I it was this was a whole different level of depth of engagement because we were doing these daily briefs that the team would sometimes a lot, usually in the order of half an hour for us to talk to him about like the latest status of COVID-19. But it was very common that these briefings would go 60 minutes or even 90 minutes, because he was asking such interesting detailed questions and I didn't expect him to ask at that level of detail.
我不是来向你推销任何东西的。我只是想让你感觉好一点。我希望每个人都健康。就是这样。我们花时间制定了一个蓝图并留了下来，然后它被忽视了。所以你当时一定在想，请打电话，请打电话，请打电话。然后他们真的打了。嗯，实际上发生的情况是，在疫情非常早期，2020年初，我曾与当时的副总统拜登和奥巴马政府合作过一点，但他和他的团队联系我，看看我是否能在COVID的早期阶段提供一些支持和建议。你知道，他，所以我做了，我的基本理念是，看，如果决策者、政策制定者想要更多地了解与健康相关的主题，作为专家，我们应该提供帮助。这是我们的工作。我们需要，这就是我们应该为公共利益所做的。但我之前也认识他，我知道他非常重视科学专业知识，让它真正处于首要地位。所以我当时想，是的，很高兴能提供帮助。所以实际上从2020年3月开始发生的事情是，他的团队要求我和另一位同事开始与他进行一系列关于COVID-19的每日简报。这是一次迷人的经历，因为虽然我之前和他相处过一段时间，但这完全是不同深度的参与，因为我们进行这些每日简报，团队有时会分配，通常大约半小时让我们和他谈谈COVID-19的最新状态。但这些简报经常会持续60分钟甚至90分钟，因为他问的问题非常有趣且详细，我没想到他会问到那个详细程度。
I mean, I was excited by it, but, but he really wanted to like get his arms around us understand like not just what's going on, but like, what do we need to do now? What do we need to be planning for in six months, 12 months? How do we prevent this thing from happening a second time around? Who is most impacted? We spent a lot of time, for example, talking about like the disparate impact of COVID-19 on black and brown communities. And the impact, for example, the school closures we're having on increasing, for example, food insecurity among for many kids, which has not been talked about enough in this country, frankly. That's exactly right. And to your point, Will, what COVID has highlighted is that so many of the issues that we're now and have been reading about in the paper, food insecurity, disparities in health, mental health, the mental health crisis that we have, including among young people. A lot of these are worse now, but they predated the pandemic. I mean, they were bad before, you know, we just were not focusing enough attention, energy and investment on it. I want to talk to you about the mental health thing because, you know, and Project Starfish, because I want you to tell everybody what Project Starfish is. It's really cool. But the mental health, clearly, it seems like mental health is the next pandemic. There is a mass shooting almost every day, and it's almost based on somebody who has had a history of mental health issues. And it seems to getting worse and worse and worse. So talk a little bit about that and tell them what Project Starfish is.
我的意思是，我对此感到兴奋，但他真的想全面了解，不仅是发生了什么，还有我们现在需要做什么？我们需要为6个月、12个月后规划什么？我们如何防止这种情况第二次发生？谁受到的影响最大？例如，我们花了很多时间讨论COVID-19对黑人和棕色人种社区的不同影响。以及学校关闭对增加许多孩子粮食不安全的影响，坦率地说，这在这个国家谈论得还不够多。完全正确。而且说到点子上了，威尔，COVID所凸显的是，我们现在在报纸上读到的许多问题，粮食不安全、健康差异、心理健康、我们所面临的心理健康危机，包括年轻人中的危机。其中许多问题现在更严重了，但它们在大流行之前就存在了。我的意思是，它们之前就很糟糕，我们只是没有投入足够的关注、精力和投资。我想和你谈谈心理健康的事情，因为，还有“海星计划”，因为我想让你告诉大家什么是“海星计划”。它真的很酷。但心理健康，显然，心理健康似乎是下一次大流行。几乎每天都有大规模枪击事件，而且几乎都是基于有心理健康问题史的人。而且它似乎变得越来越严重。所以谈谈那个，并告诉他们什么是“海星计划”。
Yeah, well, I'm glad you raised mental health. I mean, this was a huge issue. We had record rates, really, of depression, anxiety in our country, particularly among young people, incredibly high rates of suicide before COVID-19 came. And then COVID hits. And just yesterday, I spent, you know, the day at a middle school or part of the day at a middle school talking to students about what their experience of the pandemic was like. And I can't tell you how many of them said that they just, that they felt cut off from friends that they felt they didn't know how to really engage with the virtual learning. And they felt like they were falling behind. Some of them found silver linings during the pandemic. They found things that they got really excited to learn about on their own. They were able to quarantine with family and like really deepen their relationship with them. But it was a real struggle for a lot of people. So here are some thoughts on it. I think we have an opportunity now, like as a country, to really rethink how we address mental health. Not just from this standpoint of how do we prevent mental illness, but how do we recognize that mental health and well-being is more, it's about more than just saying, OK, I don't have clinical depression. I don't have a generalized anxiety disorder. That's like one half of the spectrum. The other half of the spectrum is one where we can be having pretty rotten days, you know, be operating in a funk,
是的，我很高兴你提到了心理健康。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题。在COVID-19到来之前，我们国家的抑郁症、焦虑症发病率确实达到了创纪录的水平，特别是在年轻人中，自杀率高得惊人。然后COVID来了。就在昨天，我在一所中学度过了一天，或者说是一天的一部分，和学生们谈论他们对大流行的经历。我无法告诉你他们中有多少人说他们只是感到与朋友隔绝，他们觉得不知道如何真正参与虚拟学习。他们觉得自己在落后。有些人在大流行期间发现了亮点。他们发现了自己非常兴奋地想要自学的东西。他们能够和家人一起隔离，真正加深了与他们的关系。但对很多人来说，这确实是一场挣扎。所以这里有一些想法。我认为我们现在作为一个国家，有一个机会真正重新思考我们如何解决心理健康问题。不仅仅是从我们如何预防精神疾病的角度，而是如何认识到心理健康和福祉不仅仅是说，好吧，我没有临床抑郁症。我没有广泛性焦虑症。那是光谱的一半。光谱的另一半是我们可以过得很糟糕的日子，你知道，处于一种情绪低落的状态，
you know, at a pretty low level of emotional energy, or we can be operating at the top of the end of our scale, you know, really bringing our all to our work, to our family, to our community. And we never really talk about how to do that, how to train our kids and give them a foundation for enhancing their emotional health and well-being. And we've just got to see it as part and parcel of health. So one of the things that we've been working on in our office is something we call Project Starfish. And the Starfish, you know, Starfish, it's an organism that regenerates, right? And so we think of this as an opportunity, this moment, as hard as it has been over the last 18 months for us to think, how do we want to remake ourselves as a society into not just what we were in 2019, but something potentially even better? A lot of people are thinking about this, you know, on their own. They're kind of having second thoughts, maybe about the job that they have. Like, is that really the right job? Or about maybe the balance they had with time with family and work? Maybe they want more time with family. A lot of people have moved to be closer to family and friends because they realize this is not working for our part.
你知道，处于一种相当低的情绪能量水平，或者我们可以处于我们量表的顶端，你知道，真正把我们的全部投入到我们的工作、我们的家庭、我们的社区中。我们从来没有真正谈论过如何做到这一点，如何训练我们的孩子并为他们提供增强情绪健康和福祉的基础。我们必须把它视为健康的一部分。所以我们办公室一直在做的一件事是我们称之为“海星计划”的项目。海星，你知道，海星，它是一种可以再生的生物，对吧？所以我们认为这是一个机会，这个时刻，尽管过去18个月对我们来说很艰难，让我们思考，我们想如何将自己重塑为一个社会，不仅仅是回到2019年的样子，而是可能变得更好？很多人都在自己思考这个问题。他们可能对自己的工作有了新的想法。比如，那真的是合适的工作吗？或者关于他们与家庭和工作的时间平衡？也许他们想要更多的时间陪伴家人。很多人搬到离家人和朋友更近的地方，因为他们意识到这在我们的部分行不通。
But if we don't take a real conscious approach to this and intentionally think, you know, about what kind of society we want to design post-pandemic, how do we want our workplaces to support mental health? How do we think we should be giving kids a foundation in schools for mental health and well-being? How do we think as a government we should be investing in prevention up front and in mental health rather than waiting, you know, years for problems to arise and then trying to solve them? If we don't do that now, I worry we will lose a window of opportunity to act and to fashion a stronger, more equitable, more resilient society. Can I ask you, in your position, do you have the authority, if you wanted to, let's say, if you wanted to start a required subject in public schools, like there's, you know, English, math, history, and you have to take mental wellness or whatever we would call it, do you have the authority in your job position or is that sort of the head of education? Or could you implement that unilaterally as a policy if you wanted to?
但如果我们不对此采取真正自觉的方法，并有意地思考我们想要设计什么样的后大流行社会，我们希望我们的工作场所如何支持心理健康？我们认为应该如何在学校为孩子提供心理健康和福祉的基础？我们认为政府应该如何预先投资于预防和心理健康，而不是等待问题出现几年后再试图解决它们？如果我们现在不这样做，我担心我们会失去一个行动的机会，无法塑造一个更强大、更公平、更有韧性的社会。我可以问你吗，在你的职位上，你是否有权，如果你想的话，比如说，如果你想在公立学校开设一门必修课，就像有英语、数学、历史一样，你必须学习心理健康或无论我们称之为什么，你在你的职位上有权这样做吗，还是那是教育部门负责的？或者如果你想的话，你可以单方面将其作为一项政策实施吗？
It's a good question, Jason. The answer is no. And because a lot of our policy in schools, education policy, is actually very decentralized. So it's under local control. And that's why local school boards are often the ones that make decisions on things like curricula or on other subjects of what's focused on in school. But what we can do from our office, and we are actually working on an initiative right now around youth mental health, is we can build a compelling blueprint that we can work with the federal government on supporting the work with states and localities on implementing so that schools do have a sense of how to create this foundation. Because here's the thing, Jason, if you talk to parents around the country, increasingly more and more of them recognize that there's a mental health crisis among youth in this country, right? And they have questions like, is it because there's social media? Is it because there's something else? Is it like, you know, whatever the factors sociological may be? It might be because of this podcast, but yeah. You think it's having an effect.
这是一个好问题，杰森。答案是不能。因为我们在学校的许多政策，教育政策，实际上是非常分散的。所以它是在地方控制之下。这就是为什么地方学校董事会通常是决定课程或学校关注的其他学科等事项的机构。但我们办公室可以做的是，我们目前正在开展一项关于青少年心理健康的倡议，我们可以建立一个令人信服的蓝图，我们可以与联邦政府合作，支持与各州和地方合作实施，以便学校能够了解如何建立这个基础。因为事情是这样的，杰森，如果你和全国各地的家长交谈，越来越多的人认识到这个国家存在青少年心理健康危机，对吧？他们有这样的问题，是因为社交媒体吗？是因为有其他原因吗？是因为，你知道，无论社会学因素可能是什么？可能是因为这个播客，但是的。你认为它有影响。
Some damage is coming from this. Absolutely. Social media, can we just get rid of it altogether? I think it's the scourge of humanity, and I think it's destroying. Hey, granddad. Destroying. Do you want people to stay off your yard too? Well, no, look, I've always wanted to know, because I'm never going to have this chance to talk to somebody, a health official such as yourself, Admiral. So I've switched it up, and I now will eat a salad, and then I'll work out like an hour later, and I find that flipping that, I'm burning all those calories. Anyway, are you out of your mind? Don't cut me off. This is important stuff, and people want to know.
一些损害正来自这里。绝对是。社交媒体，我们能彻底摆脱它吗？我认为它是人类的祸害，我认为它正在摧毁。嘿，爷爷。摧毁。你也想让人远离你的院子吗？嗯，不，看，我一直想知道，因为我永远不会有这个机会和一个像你这样的卫生官员交谈，海军上将。所以我改变了方式，我现在会吃沙拉，然后一小时后锻炼，我发现颠倒过来，我正在燃烧所有那些卡路里。总之，你疯了吗？别打断我。这是重要的事情，人们想知道。
You want to know workout before eating. He talked about remaking you. I'm remaking myself, and it's incredible. I want to know one thing. One thing, Dr. Murphy, because you were talking about, you touched on the mental health, which leads me to the next thing, which is loneliness. I know you've done a ton of research on loneliness, which I think is fascinating. Like, who researches loneliness? And I want to, I think it's such a common fear, especially as one gets older, and a lot of people are embarrassed to admit it, right? Admit that that's a fear, and I know it's one of mine, and I think everybody thinks about it. Oh, we couldn't tell, because you've just spent 10 minutes on this question.
你想知道饭前锻炼。他谈到了重塑你。我正在重塑我自己，这太不可思议了。我想知道一件事。一件事，墨菲医生，因为你谈到了，你触及了心理健康，这引出了下一件事，那就是孤独。我知道你对孤独做了大量的研究，我认为这很迷人。比如，谁会研究孤独？我想，我认为这是一种非常普遍的恐惧，尤其是随着年龄的增长，很多人不好意思承认，对吧？承认那是一种恐惧，我知道这是我的恐惧之一，我想每个人都会想到它。哦，我们看不出来，因为你刚才在这个问题上花了10分钟。
Right. Anyway, where are you all going? Where are you going? Is my question too long? Where are you going? I see them back in a way. I don't know what that's all about. But yeah, you know, it's really interesting. I totally didn't think I was going to discuss, think about research or work on that issue of loneliness when I started my term as surgeon general. But even what happened to me is I spent a lot of time talking to people around the country. And what they would say to me are things like, you know, I feel like I've got to handle all of these struggles in my life by myself, or I feel if I disappear tomorrow, nobody would even notice, or I walk around just feeling totally invisible. And this wasn't just, you know, people who are living alone at the end stages of their life who were saying this. I'm talking about college kids on campus that's surrounded by thousands of other kids who were saying this.
对。总之，你们要去哪里？你们要去哪里？我的问题太长了吗？你们要去哪里？我看到他们以某种方式回来了。我不知道那是什么意思。但是的，你知道，这真的很有趣。当我开始担任卫生局局长时，我完全没想过要讨论、思考或研究孤独这个问题。但即使是发生在我身上的事情是，我花了很多时间与全国各地的人交谈。他们对我说的是，比如，你知道，我觉得我必须独自处理生活中的所有这些挣扎，或者我觉得如果我明天消失了，没人会注意到，或者我走来走去只是感到完全隐形。这不仅仅是，你知道，那些独自生活在生命最后阶段的人在说这话。我说的是校园里的大学生，被成千上万的其他孩子包围着，他们也在说这话。
I'm talking about people who go to work every day and busy office settings surrounded by lots of people who were saying this. Yeah, I've heard it because Sean, you were saying that you had gone because of having to wear a mask. You went to Gelson's and nobody recognized you and you felt like just you were invisible for the first time. That's correct. And then at the checkout, I pulled my mask down and I felt better about myself. And you got back into your Tesla and you said to Scotty, I just feel so invisible. Yeah. Admiral, tell me, what is, you know, so much about how to keep your body right and to stay healthy. What is the least healthy thing you do to yourself that you probably should not tell America, but you're going to on the smart list podcast? What's your guilty damage? Is it sugar? Is it salt? Or do you smoke three packs a day? That's what it is, right?
我说的是那些每天去工作，在繁忙的办公室环境中被很多人包围的人，他们也在说这话。是的，我听说过，因为肖恩，你说过你因为必须戴口罩。你去Gelson's超市，没人认出你，你第一次觉得你只是隐形的。没错。然后在结账时，我摘下口罩，我对自己感觉好多了。然后你回到你的特斯拉，你对斯科蒂说，我只是觉得太隐形了。是的。海军上将，告诉我，你非常了解如何保持身体健康和保持健康。你对自己做的最不健康的事情是什么，你可能不应该告诉美国，但你会在“SmartLess”播客上说出来？你的罪恶感是什么？是糖吗？是盐吗？还是你一天抽三包烟？就是那个，对吧？
No, no, I'm not going to. I don't smoke three packs a day. But here's where I am actually really falling short. There's your own labels on those things. Go ahead. Yes, actually, there is a Surgeon General's warning on cigarettes and an alcohol bottle, which is actually the primary reason that people know the title is Surgeon General. Do they see it on these things? And some people think I spent all my day stamping boxes and cigarettes with warnings, but that is not the case. So what are you doing that is bad? So what I'm doing that's where I'm falling short is around sleep, right? So what I really should be doing is I should be sleeping somewhere around eight hours a night, seven to nine is what most people need. I should be sleeping at a consistent time each night, and I should be keeping distractions away from me when I sleep like phones. Sleep hygiene.
不，不，我不会。我不一天抽三包烟。但这就是我实际上真的做得不够的地方。你自己对那些东西有标签。继续。是的，实际上，香烟和酒瓶上确实有卫生局局长的警告，这实际上是人们知道“卫生局局长”这个头衔的主要原因。他们能在这些东西上看到它吗？有些人认为我整天都在香烟盒上盖警告印章，但事实并非如此。那你做错了什么？所以我做得不够的地方是关于睡眠，对吧？所以我真正应该做的是，我应该每晚睡大约八小时，七到九小时是大多数人需要的。我应该每晚在固定的时间睡觉，我应该在睡觉时让干扰远离我，比如手机。睡眠卫生。
Exactly, sleep hygiene. And that's something I want to do, but I've struggled with that. I haven't prioritized. And I've executed on getting to that. And is that because of work? Is that because of family? Is that because of the balance of the two, or you've always been wired that way? It's work. He's got to keep his phone on for Biden to hit him with a text in case he's... And he's sending you a bunch of kiddies on skateboards, right? And that's keeping you up late and it's pissing you off. You got to just go on Do Not Disturb on the... Oh, I love this one. Yeah, yeah. No, no, that's definitely not the case for the present, but it's actually a couple of things.
没错，睡眠卫生。这是我想做的事情，但我一直在为此挣扎。我没有优先考虑它。我还没有执行到那一步。这是因为工作吗？是因为家庭吗？是因为两者的平衡，还是你一直都是那样的人？是工作。他必须保持手机开机，以便拜登在万一他需要时给他发短信……而且他给你发了一堆滑板上的小猫，对吧？这让你熬夜，让你很生气。你必须在……上开启“请勿打扰”。哦，我喜欢这个。是的，是的。不，不，总统肯定不是这样，但实际上是几件事。
I mean, one is like, I've never been somebody who's been consistent about sleep across my life. It's just been kind of a life-long struggle. So the second thing is I generally have operated as a night owl most of my life, but I have to get up very early so that doesn't make for a good combination. And third is like I have kids, right? So I have small kids, and they're three and a half and five. And my five-year-old son, he just refuses to sleep if I'm not actually next to him in the bed, right? Like he threatens to go on strike, all this kind of stuff. So, you know, slightly embarrassing because I'm probably a bad parent for this, but we've just let him sleep with me and my daughter sleeps with my wife and we somehow figure it out.
我的意思是，一是，我从来都不是一个一生中睡眠都很规律的人。这一直是一种终身的挣扎。所以第二件事是，我一生中大部分时间通常都是夜猫子，但我必须很早起床，所以这组合起来不太好。第三是，我有孩子，对吧？所以我有两个小孩，他们分别是三岁半和五岁。我五岁的儿子，如果我不在床上陪着他，他拒绝睡觉，对吧？他威胁要罢工，诸如此类的东西。所以，你知道，有点尴尬，因为我可能是一个糟糕的父母，但我们只是让他和我一起睡，我女儿和我妻子一起睡，我们以某种方式解决了它。
But half the night, he's like punching me, kicking me, like just making sure I'm still there. I know how to construct a pillow wall between me and my kids, like no one's business. Because if anything touches me, I'm up. I've got to create a little pillow wall there. I still, my sons are going to hate that I'm saying this out loud. They're almost 13 next week in 11, and they still, at night, I have to lie with them in bed and put them to bed in that way until they fall asleep. That's so great. And it's what we do for our kids. It's just the way it is, but I will say this, Admiral, and I'm sorry, I hate to pull rank on you.
但半夜里，他会打我、踢我，就像确保我还在那里一样。我知道如何在我和我的孩子之间筑起一堵枕头墙，就像没人能比得上一样。因为如果有什么东西碰到我，我就醒了。我必须在那里筑起一堵小枕头墙。我仍然，我的儿子们会讨厌我大声说出这一点。他们下周就快13岁了，还有11岁，他们仍然，在晚上，我必须躺在床上陪他们，以那种方式哄他们睡觉，直到他们睡着。那太棒了。这就是我们为孩子所做的。就是这样，但我会说这一点，海军上将，我很抱歉，我讨厌对你摆架子。
Nice, nice. Literally. But I'm like a field marshal of sleep over here because once I put the kids to bed, and these guys know about 9, 9.30, I'm in bed. I read a little bit, old school actual book. I put my device away and I go to sleep and it's very important. My sleep is very, very important to me and I get up super early. So I don't sleep 9-9, but I'll sleep sort of 9.30 and I'll get up at 5.30 or 6 most days.
不错，不错。字面意思。但我在这里就像一个睡眠元帅，因为一旦我哄孩子们睡觉，这些家伙知道大约9点、9点半，我就上床了。我读一点书，老派的实体书。我把设备收起来，然后睡觉，这非常重要。我的睡眠对我来说非常、非常重要，我起得很早。所以我不是9点睡，但我会大约9点半睡，大多数日子我会在5点半或6点起床。
And I'm just saying that because I want to flex that I have better sleep hygiene than the Surgeon General. And these are things you don't often get to do. No, no. You totally do. You totally do. And so that's an area I've got to work on. Well, listen, and that's the reason I said it because now what I'm going to say is I'd love to have the opportunity to come over and help you work through it and I can talk you through it.
我之所以这么说，是因为我想炫耀一下我的睡眠卫生比卫生局局长好。这些是你通常做不到的事情。不，不。你完全可以。你完全可以。所以这是一个我必须努力的领域。好吧，听着，这就是我这么说的原因，因为现在我要说的是，我很乐意有机会过去帮你解决这个问题，我可以和你谈谈。
And I feel like I could be a real asset. Yeah, there's nothing creepy about that. Just lay down next to him, read him a story. I'm a sleep asset. Sorry. I was going to say, like, you know, the last thing I find is really powerful about sleep is actually, and it sounds like a bit of a will does. It's like, get yourself in the right place. Like when you start sleeping.
我觉得我可以成为一个真正的资产。是的，这没什么令人毛骨悚然的。只要躺在他旁边，给他读个故事。我是一个睡眠资产。抱歉。我想说的是，你知道，我发现关于睡眠的最后一件事确实很有力量，而且听起来威尔做了一些。就像，让自己处于正确的位置。就像当你开始睡觉时。
So because our minds are just like going a thousand miles an hour in a thousand directions, right? And like how to like quieten our mind and calm our mind before we get on that runways. It's like getting on the right. That's right. And I've just had, I think you and I are just having the same idea at the same time. Are you about to appoint me the sleep czar? We need a sleep czar and it should be me. You've been putting people to sleep for years.
因为我们的思想就像以每小时一千英里的速度向一千个方向前进，对吧？以及如何在我们在跑道上之前让我们的思想安静下来并平静下来。这就像走上正确的跑道。没错。我想你和我只是在同一时间有了同样的想法。你打算任命我为睡眠沙皇吗？我们需要一个睡眠沙皇，那应该是我。你多年来一直让人入睡。
Well, this is unbelievable. We've got all we've got the last season of Ozark queued up and everybody will be out. They'll be out and believe me. Return to Ozark is the one that I'm doing. You guys are hysterical. And we will be right back. All right, back to the show. I want to talk about climate change because look, I prefer to sleep.
好吧，这太不可思议了。我们已经排好了《黑钱胜地》的最后一季，每个人都会睡着的。他们会睡着的，相信我。回到《黑钱胜地》是我正在做的。你们太搞笑了。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目。我想谈谈气候变化，因为看，我更喜欢睡觉。
Stop looking out the window. It's not happening like that. That's weather. I'll just stare at the window. I prefer cooler climates. I hate when it's hot. So I'm really angry about climate change. But talk to me like how does climate change and your position work together?
别再往窗外看了。它不是那样发生的。那是天气。我只是盯着窗户。我更喜欢凉爽的气候。我讨厌天气热的时候。所以我对气候变化真的很生气。但跟我谈谈，气候变化和你的职位是如何共同作用的？
What are you doing? What should we, is there any good news about freaking climate change? Are we doing anything to make it better? Well, so the first question, like my office actually does work on climate change. We did actually work a lot before when I was surgeon general. We actually had worked on an initiative with the NIH and with President Obama on climate change and health. Because it turns out there are some pretty big impacts of climate change on health for a whole bunch of reasons we could talk about. And now going forward, actually, in the administration, we recently set up, you know, in the Department of Health and Human Services,
你在做什么？我们应该，关于该死的气候变化有什么好消息吗？我们正在做任何事情来让它变得更好吗？嗯，所以第一个问题，我的办公室实际上确实在研究气候变化。当我担任卫生局局长时，我们实际上确实做了很多工作。我们实际上与NIH和奥巴马总统一起制定了一项关于气候变化和健康的倡议。因为事实证明，由于我们可以谈论的各种原因，气候变化对健康有一些相当大的影响。现在展望未来，实际上，在政府中，我们最近在卫生与公众服务部设立了，
an office of climate change and health equity as part of a much broader push on investing and addressing climate change, not just in domestically, but in terms of global action that we're embarking on. But look, it can happen fast enough because these changes are happening in real time. We're starting to see them. And sometimes people say, oh, it seems like the global increase in temperature is really mild because they think like a degree or two. What's a big deal? But the downstream consequences are really quite extraordinary. So there is a lot of action and investment happening.
一个气候变化与健康公平办公室，作为我们正在进行的不仅在国内，而且在全球行动方面投资和解决气候变化这一更广泛推动的一部分。但看，它能发生得足够快吗，因为这些变化正在实时发生。我们开始看到它们了。有时人们说，哦，全球气温的升高似乎真的很温和，因为他们认为像一两度。有什么大不了的？但下游后果确实非常非凡。所以有很多行动和投资正在发生。
The question is, are we going to be able to do enough? Are we going to be able to sustain it? If this is the kind of thing which, you know, our investment and our attention to taxes and wanes, depending on who's in office at the time or the politics of the moment, that's not going to serve us and our kids well. This is one of those things we've got to recognize. It doesn't matter what your party is. This is a threat to all of us. And so we've got to invest in addressing it just like we would any other health issue.
问题是，我们能够做得足够多吗？我们能够维持它吗？如果这是那种，你知道，我们对税收的投资和关注会随着当时谁在任或当时的政治而起伏的事情，那对我们和我们的孩子没有好处。这是我们必须认识到的事情之一。无论你的党派是什么，这对我们所有人都是一种威胁。所以我们必须像对待任何其他健康问题一样，投资于解决它。
All sorts of jokes aside, we are in an existential crisis right now. It is alarming where we're at. And we don't talk a lot about stuff like this on this show. But we are in an alarming place right now on this planet. And we are in an absolute climate emergency. Unless people come to terms with that and quickly, it's going to be over before we know it. And I know it, again, I don't want to sound like a doomsday. Yeah, but it's one of those things, though, that like...
撇开所有的玩笑不谈，我们现在正处于一场生存危机中。我们所处的位置令人担忧。在这个节目中，我们不常谈论这样的事情。但我们现在在这个星球上处于一个令人担忧的地方。我们正处于绝对的气候紧急状态。除非人们接受这一点，而且要快，否则在我们知道之前一切就结束了。我知道，再次重申，我不想听起来像个末日预言者。是的，但这是那种事情之一，尽管……
It is beyond urgent. So many things like what can we do, right? It seems to... Yes, you can inform us that it's happening, but what can we do? Okay, so if we're in the fortunate position of buying a new car, we buy electric rather than gas. If we, you know, there are certain little things you can do. But for the most part, it's up to the government and the people to implement. Jason, I know you're concerned because you were telling me the other day you were up all night.
这不仅仅是紧急。很多事情，比如我们能做什么，对吧？它似乎……是的，你可以通知我们它正在发生，但我们能做什么？好吧，所以如果我们处于购买新车的幸运位置，我们买电动的而不是汽油的。如果我们，你知道，你可以做某些小事。但在很大程度上，这取决于政府和人民去实施。杰森，我知道你很担心，因为你前几天告诉我你整晚没睡。
You went from room to room to room and you kept lighting on. You turned on the lights and you went to the guest house and you went to the other room. And then you went to the other thing you're building. You kept going from room to room and you got in the pool and it was warm. You got in the pool and you were just like trying to think, what can we, what can I do? I don't know. Yeah, go ahead. Can I ask you guys a question, actually?
你从一个房间走到另一个房间，你一直开着灯。你打开灯，你去了客房，你去了另一个房间。然后你去了你正在建造的另一个东西。你一直从一个房间走到另一个房间，你进了游泳池，水是温的。你进了游泳池，你只是在想，我们能，我能做什么？我不知道。是的，继续。我可以问你们一个问题吗，实际上？
Yes. You know, on this theme of just trying to rethink what life we want after this pandemic is over, I'm curious, look, when you guys think about your experience over the last 18 months, I'm curious, what was tough about it, where there are also things that were unexpected and good that you feel like, hey, I want to keep that in my life post pandemic. I don't want to go back to the way I was in 2019. Well, it was that quarantining with everybody, you know, having all that family time together was a silver lining a bit. I think, I hope, many people experienced sort of that forced gathering we were all into.
是的。你知道，在这个试图重新思考大流行结束后我们想要什么样的生活的主题上，我很好奇，看，当你们思考过去18个月的经历时，我很好奇，其中有什么困难，是否有意想不到的好事，让你觉得，嘿，我想在后大流行时代保持这一点。我不想回到2019年的样子。嗯，就是和大家一起隔离，你知道，拥有所有那些家庭时光，这有点像一线希望。我想，我希望，许多人经历了那种我们都陷入的被迫聚会。
I really gained from that a lot. Me too. It was incredible. Obviously, it was, you know, so many lives were lost that it's almost beyond comprehension in such a short amount of time. But, you know, for my immediate family, it was a very, it was a time for us to come together. There was a lot, we actually had a lot of healing in our family in that time. That was incredible that otherwise would not have otherwise happened. And that I'm very, very thankful for it, if I'm being honest.
我确实从中获益良多。我也是。这太不可思议了。显然，这是，你知道，太多的生命失去了，以至于在如此短的时间内几乎无法理解。但是，你知道，对于我的直系亲属来说，这是我们聚在一起的时间。有很多，我们实际上在那段时间里在家庭中有很多治愈。那太不可思议了，否则就不会发生。如果我诚实的话，我对此非常、非常感激。
Speaking of that, speaking of the terrible numbers of lives lost, do you allow yourself to pat on the back is not the right term, but do you realize how many lives you've saved by being the man in charge right now as far as rolling out this life-saving policies and some of the mandates more recently that have come out? I mean, look at how many lives have been saved from just the mandate of, like, you can't smoke in certain places. Like, that saves a lot of health problems with secondhand smoke. But this directly about the mandates of these vaccines, all these lives that are not being wasted because of the courage of some of the policies that have been put forth, that's got to feel good, again, is not probably the right word, but it's rewarding. Yeah.
说到那个，说到失去生命的惨重数字，你允许自己拍拍背不是正确的词，但你意识到作为现在负责的人，在推出这些拯救生命的政策和最近出台的一些强制令方面，你挽救了多少生命吗？我的意思是，看看仅仅因为强制令，比如，你在某些地方不能吸烟，挽救了多少生命。就像，这挽救了很多二手烟带来的健康问题。但这是直接关于这些疫苗的强制令，所有这些没有被浪费的生命，因为所提出的一些政策的勇气，这一定感觉很好，再次重申，可能不是正确的词，但它是值得的。是的。
Well, I mean, sir, I do feel grateful to have the chance to be involved in this kind of work, because you're right. This is one of those unusual circumstances in life where you can draw a very straight line between policies around backstanding people and life-saving, and we're seeing that now happen again and again and again. But, you know, I'll tell you, like, you know, this is actually one of the reasons why I took this job, you know, after he was elected, you know, when the president and his team asked, you know, you need to come back and serve a certain general, it was not a hard decision. And not just because I had been, you know, advising him, you know, over that past year, but I remember talking to my wife about it. And we said, you know, our kids are going to be studying this pandemic in school in five years and 10 years and 15 years. Like, people will be looking at this for generations to come and trying to glean lessons from it.
嗯，我的意思是，先生，我确实感到很感激有机会参与这种工作，因为你是对的。这是生活中那些不寻常的情况之一，你可以画出一条非常直的线，连接关于支持人们的政策和拯救生命，我们现在看到这种情况一次又一次地发生。但是，你知道，我会告诉你，就像，你知道，这实际上是我接受这份工作的原因之一，你知道，在他当选后，你知道，当总统和他的团队问，你知道，你需要回来服务卫生局局长时，这不是一个艰难的决定。不仅仅是因为我一直在，你知道，在那过去的一年里建议他，但我记得和我妻子谈过这件事。我们说，你知道，我们的孩子五年、十年、十五年后会在学校学习这场大流行。就像，人们会在未来几代人中研究这一点，并试图从中收集教训。
Ask what went wrong, what went right. And at some point, our kids are going to ask us, like... You'd be on Mars because this planet's uninhabited. When they're on Mars, look at me. Well, you know, I think at some point, our kids are going to ask us, like, Mama, Papa, what did you do? Right, yeah. You lived through it. What did you do? Right.
问什么出了问题，什么做对了。在某个时候，我们的孩子会问我们，比如……你会去火星，因为这个星球无人居住。当他们在火星上时，看着我。嗯，你知道，我认为在某个时候，我们的孩子会问我们，比如，妈妈，爸爸，你们做了什么？对，是的。你们经历了它。你们做了什么？对。
And I want us to be able to tell them that we did absolutely everything that we could at a time where this pandemic was ravaging our country and the world, where we and our family had lost 10 members of our family to this disease and had seen many others hospitalized. Like, we wanted to be able to tell them, look, you know what? We did everything we could that we didn't sit home and say, you know what? You know, it'd be a lot harder to, like, want a government with a much easier life, you know, here, you know, the private sector. We didn't want to give excuses. We wanted to say that, you know what? We ran toward the fire here.
我希望我们能告诉他们，在这个大流行肆虐我们国家和世界的时候，我们确实尽了我们所能做的一切，我们和我们的家人在这个疾病中失去了10名家庭成员，并看到许多其他人住院。就像，我们想能够告诉他们，看，你知道吗？我们尽了我们所能，我们没有坐在家里说，你知道吗？你知道，想要一个生活轻松得多的政府，你知道，在这里，你知道，私营部门。我们不想找借口。我们想说，你知道吗？我们在这里冲向了火。
And so there's still a lot of work to do. Well, I think there was a lot of people, though. Like you, like, speaking right, Sean, you ran towards the fire. By the way, if the fire is the chin chin on sunset, you ran right towards it. I wish that was the approach with climate, sort of addressing the immediacy of it, because I feel like if people lived traditionally to be 150 years old, instead of, say, 90 years old, then maybe we would enact more sort of strict policies because we would actually be alive enough to reap the benefits of it. Or the lack of implementing those policies, we would be exposed to the consequences of not acting. In other words, the cynic in me says that the politicians are not putting forth really good policies because they all figure,
所以还有很多工作要做。嗯，但我认为确实有很多人。就像你，就像，说得对，肖恩，你冲向了火。顺便说一句，如果火是日落大道上的下巴，你直接冲向了它。我希望那是对待气候的方法，某种程度上解决它的紧迫性，因为我觉得如果人们传统上能活到150岁，而不是，比如说，90岁，那么也许我们会制定更严格的政策，因为我们实际上会活得足够长来享受它的好处。或者不实施这些政策，我们将暴露在不采取行动的后果中。换句话说，我内心愤世嫉俗的一面说，政客们没有提出真正好的政策，因为他们都认为，
well, we're going to be dead before this planet roasts and they're not thinking about their kids. And they should be because it really is going to, things are going to come home to roost after we're all gone. We should be thinking about that, right? We should be. Look, if you ask me what do we need to truly accelerate our work on climate change, I would tell you that we need political courage. We need accurate information to be shared with people, not rampant misinformation that you see on social media right now. And the third thing we need is true grassroots mobilization, right? Those are the three things we need in our country and around the world to really address climate change, because you're right.
嗯，在我们这个星球被烤焦之前，我们可能就已经不在了，而他们并没有为自己的孩子考虑。他们应该考虑，因为这确实会发生，等我们都走了之后，后果就会显现出来。我们应该考虑这一点，对吧？我们确实应该。听着，如果你问我，我们需要什么来真正加速我们在气候变化方面的工作，我会告诉你，我们需要政治勇气。我们需要与人们分享准确的信息，而不是像你现在在社交媒体上看到的那种猖獗的错误信息。第三点我们需要的是真正的草根动员，对吧？这就是我们在国内和世界各地真正应对气候变化所需要的三件事，因为你是对的。
It's not just about us, right? It's about our kids. It's about future generations. Do we really feel that it's okay to say that, yeah, we're not sure that our grandkids will be able to live in a world that's truly hospitable, that they're not going to be able to enjoy the things that we enjoy? That does not compute, I think, for people across the political spectrum. Yet, if you look at the way that this has been politicized, this issue, if you look also at the way that misinformation has spread rampantly about it, despite how much scientific consensus there is on climate change, you realize there's a disservice being done.
这不仅仅是关于我们，对吧？这是关于我们的孩子。这是关于未来几代人。我们真的觉得说“是的，我们不确定我们的孙辈是否能生活在一个真正适宜居住的世界里，他们将无法享受我们所享受的东西”是可以的吗？我认为，对于政治光谱两端的人来说，这都说不通。然而，如果你看看这个问题被政治化的方式，如果你也看看关于它的错误信息是如何猖獗传播的，尽管在气候变化问题上存在如此多的科学共识，你就会意识到这是一种伤害。
Look, I got to say on this point about the misinformation, we talked about social media earlier, but early in the summer, I issued a Surgeon General's advisory on the harms of health misinformation, just recognizing that not just with COVID, but more broadly. It was awesome. I remember that. It was fantastic. Thank you. But one of the things that was frustrating me is that misinformation, I knew people had been lying for generations, but it's the speed and scale and sophistication with which it's been spreading aided and abetted by tech platforms. It's really made now so different from the past.
听着，关于错误信息这一点，我必须说，我们之前谈到了社交媒体，但在夏初，我发布了一份卫生局局长关于健康错误信息危害的建议，不仅是针对新冠，而是更广泛地认识到这一点。那太棒了。我记得。那太棒了。谢谢。但让我感到沮丧的一件事是，我知道人们几代人以来一直在撒谎，但错误信息传播的速度、规模和复杂程度，在科技平台的帮助和教唆下，确实让现在与过去大不相同。
What I've always said to the platforms and continues to say publicly and privately is, it is not okay from a moral standpoint for them to allow the rampant spread of this misinformation, knowing it's causing harm and knowing it's dividing us further, and to just sit back and not do enough about it or to tink around the edges and say, we're trying to address it or, hey, look over here at all the good things that we're doing. It's like, imagine if I ran a hospital and I was treating people pretty well for heart attacks and pneumonia and stuff, but I had a really high rate of line infections and surgical side infections and blood clots, because I just wasn't cleaning my procedures and I wasn't taking the precautions I need.
我一直对这些平台说，并且继续公开和私下地说，从道德角度来看，允许这种错误信息的猖獗传播，在明知它造成伤害并进一步分裂我们的情况下，却袖手旁观而不采取足够措施，或者只是在边缘修修补补，说“我们正在努力解决它”或者“嘿，看看我们正在做的所有好事”，这是不对的。这就像，想象一下如果我经营一家医院，我治疗心脏病发作和肺炎等疾病的效果还不错，但我有很高的管路感染、手术部位感染和血栓发生率，因为我没有清理我的程序，也没有采取我需要的预防措施。
Would anybody say, that's okay. We'll forget about all those safety issues, because we would say, no, you got to do the right thing and you got to do it safely. Right. The same moral standards should apply to these platforms. There's a very clear health risk and health damage with the misinformation, so why not make that as illegal as driving too fast or driving without a seatbelt or smoking in a bar? I agree. It should be against the law because it's creating health harm.
有人会说，那没关系吗？我们会忘记所有这些安全问题，因为我们会说，不，你必须做正确的事，而且你必须安全地做。对。同样的道德标准也应该适用于这些平台。错误信息存在非常明确的健康风险和健康损害，那么为什么不让它像超速驾驶、不系安全带驾驶或在酒吧吸烟一样违法呢？我同意。它应该被定为违法，因为它正在造成健康损害。
What's tough for you is you have to find different ways to try to sell the American public on doing things that are good for them and encouraging them to do it. There's a culture in this country of doing things that are against the public interests by other groups. It's insane that nobody does anything about it. There's no controversy when it comes to the environment. There's no debate to be had. They say, well, there's these other times. There's no debate on it. There's no debate when it comes to the virus.
对你来说困难的是，你必须找到不同的方法来试图说服美国公众做对他们有益的事情，并鼓励他们去做。这个国家有一种文化，就是其他群体做违背公共利益的事情。没有人对此采取任何行动，这太疯狂了。在环境问题上没有争议。没有辩论可言。他们说，嗯，还有其他时候。对此没有辩论。在病毒问题上也没有辩论。
The fact that we've allowed these things to occur is absurd. Look, it is frustrating because I'll tell you as a doctor even long before I was in government, the most frustrating moments are when you have somebody who's sick and you know what they need, but you can't get it to them. Those are the most frustrating moments. Those are even more frustrating than the moments where we don't have a cure for something. It's like you have the cure. You have the preventive tool, but you can't actually get it for somebody because the misinformation is some other reason.
我们允许这些事情发生的事实是荒谬的。听着，这很令人沮丧，因为我告诉你，作为一名医生，甚至在我进入政府工作很久之前，最令人沮丧的时刻就是当你有一个病人，你知道他们需要什么，但你却无法提供给他们。那些是最令人沮丧的时刻。那些甚至比我们对某种疾病没有治愈方法的时候更令人沮丧。就像你有治愈方法。你有预防工具，但你却无法真正为某人提供它，因为错误信息或其他原因。
They don't take the vaccine, but then when they get sick, they do come to you at the hospital to get fixed. Yeah, but I think there are a lot of people, though, who have been misled in our country. This is why I don't entirely fault folks themselves for some of these decisions, because if you are consuming a huge amount of misinformation in an echo chamber and are being essentially led to believe that that's all accurate, that's coming from trusted sources, then why wouldn't you think that some of these, COVID's not real, the vaccine's not good for you or some of these other fallacies. So this is why I think also that we have to, if we don't do something about the information environment in which we're operating. And the misinformation.
他们不接种疫苗，但当他们生病时，他们确实会来医院找你治疗。是的，但我认为我们国家有很多被误导的人。这就是为什么我并不完全责怪人们自己做出这些决定，因为如果你在一个回音室里消费了大量的错误信息，并且基本上被引导相信这些都是准确的，这些信息来自可信来源，那么你为什么不认为其中一些，比如新冠不是真的，疫苗对你不好，或者其他一些谬论呢？所以这就是为什么我认为，如果我们不改变我们所处的环境，如果我们不解决错误信息的问题。
It's not even just COVID. Everything. It's climate change. It's like health reform. Everything becomes. And is that something that you can drive from your office, that sort of that policy initiative to sort of try to not regulate the internet? Well, you were saying that you can suggest things, but there's nothing that you can actually, you can't mandate it. I think that these are things that have to come from a lot of different places and there needs to be a consensus, right?
这甚至不仅仅是新冠。一切都是。气候变化也是。就像医疗改革。一切都变成了这样。这是你可以从你的办公室推动的事情吗，那种试图不监管互联网的政策倡议？嗯，你刚才说你可以建议一些事情，但你实际上没有什么可以做的，你不能强制执行。我认为这些事情必须来自许多不同的地方，并且需要达成共识，对吧？
Am I right? Well, so you see, yeah. So what we can do is like, we can certainly draw attention to a draw, like national strategies for this work together with the legislature, which form, you know, creates laws and regulations and work with other branches of government to use levers to push, you know, folks to do the right thing. But ultimately, I'll tell you, government, this is not a problem government alone can solve because in people, it's when they speak up with their voices and say, look, we're not tolerating this anymore. We don't want to use a platform that's not curbing, you know, harmful information that our kids are being exposed to and others are exposed to. Like it's only when people vote with their feet, ultimately, that you can have the biggest effect. So it's not just a government shouldn't do something and can't make an impact.
我说得对吗？嗯，你看，是的。所以我们可以做的是，我们可以肯定地引起人们对这项工作的关注，制定国家战略，与立法机构合作，制定法律和法规，并与其他政府部门合作，利用杠杆推动人们做正确的事。但最终，我告诉你，政府，这不是政府单独能解决的问题，因为在人们心中，当他们发出自己的声音说，看，我们不再容忍这一点了。我们不想使用一个不遏制我们孩子和其他人所接触到的有害信息的平台。就像只有当人们用脚投票时，你才能产生最大的影响。所以这不仅仅是政府不应该做某事，也不是政府不能产生影响。
But I'm just saying that, you know, for a lot of these companies, it's when their users start leaving that they worry, right? It's when their advertisers start leaving that they worry. And what I think is that this goes, the laws of, as I think of it, like morality and humanity are more important than any other law, right? And we have a moral responsibility to take care of one another, not harm one another, to do the right thing, not because we're obligated to by law, but because it's the right thing to do. I love that. And that's the cultural difference in this country that does not exist enough in this country that I love a lot. And I've never said that, Bob, that I really do love living in this country and I've lived here for many years. It doesn't exist enough.
但我只是说，对于很多这些公司来说，当他们的用户开始离开时，他们才会担心，对吧？当他们的广告商开始离开时，他们才会担心。我认为，这就像我认为的道德和人性的法则比任何其他法律都重要，对吧？我们有道德责任去照顾彼此，不去伤害彼此，去做正确的事，不是因为法律规定我们必须这样做，而是因为这是正确的事。我喜欢这一点。这是这个国家的一种文化差异，在这个国家还不够存在，我非常喜欢。我从来没有说过，鲍勃，我真的很喜欢住在这个国家，我已经在这里住了很多年了。它还不够存在。
And it's, you're only as strong as your weakest link. And people don't seem to understand that. They can't get a grasp on it. And then there's too much of like, yeah, but I need to get mine. And I know that that's at the heart of how this country was founded. It was about sort of exploring whatever, no ceiling to whatever success you could have economically, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, and that nobody was going to hold you back. But you have to understand that we are going to, we are going to sink unless everybody starts bailing at the same rate. Right.
而且，你只有最薄弱的环节那么强大。人们似乎不明白这一点。他们无法理解它。而且有太多的“是的，但我需要得到我的那份”。我知道这是这个国家建立的核心。它是关于探索任何东西，你在经济上能取得的成功没有上限，等等等等，没有人会阻碍你。但你必须明白，除非每个人都以同样的速度开始排水，否则我们都会沉没。对。
Here's the reason I feel optimistic about this will, though, is that I actually think that the majority of people in our country share the sentiment that they want to do the right thing, that they have a sense of obligation to one another. And then when push comes to shove, they actually reach for a better spirit for a better cause. They seek to serve and help one another. Because you see that play out in communities day in, day out. You saw that a lot during COVID. But I think what happens is that there's a very vocal minority. There are people who I think manipulate folks for gain in one way or another. And it distorts things.
这就是我对此感到乐观的原因，威尔，因为我实际上认为我们国家的大多数人都有这种共识，他们想做正确的事，他们对彼此有一种义务感。当关键时刻到来时，他们实际上会追求一种更好的精神，为了一个更好的事业。他们寻求服务和帮助彼此。因为你每天都能在社区中看到这一点。你在新冠期间看到了很多。但我认为发生的事情是，有一个非常直言不讳的少数群体。我认为有些人为了某种利益操纵人们。这扭曲了事情。
It leads us to believe that we're a country that's more deeply divided than we actually are. Whereas there's a large, silent majority of people in our country who I think care deeply want to do the right thing, want us all to get through this together. I believe that. So that's why I think these changes, cultural changes, ultimately are the most powerful forces that drive policy change in the long term. And that cultural resurgence of care, compassion, kindness, and love, that has to come from a grassroots level. That's why I, you know, some of those people ask me like, Surgeon General, why do you talk about love so much? I talk about love because it's the most powerful medicine that we have. It's a force that we need now more than ever.
它让我们相信我们是一个比实际情况分裂得更严重的国家。然而，我们国家有一个庞大的、沉默的大多数人，我认为他们非常关心，想做正确的事，希望我们所有人能一起度过难关。我相信这一点。所以这就是为什么我认为这些变化，文化上的变化，最终是长期推动政策变革的最强大的力量。那种关怀、同情、善良和爱的文化复兴，必须来自草根层面。这就是为什么，你知道，有些人问我，卫生局局长，你为什么这么频繁地谈论爱？我谈论爱是因为它是我们拥有的最强大的药物。这是我们现在比以往任何时候都更需要的一种力量。
Also, it's all exacerbated by the fact that we can't see each other or interact with each other and be connected. And once we, once you actually see somebody and connect them and listen to them and hear them, I think everything you're saying is true. It makes it more valuable when you can connect and even touch somebody, hug somebody, talk to somebody, listen to somebody. It all helps to your point. And you've been very constant and consistent, Mr. Surgeon General, in being that comforting, non-emotional, non-political sort of center of common sense in our country with this tough time. And so thank you for that and please continue. And I love that you keep going back on to, falling back on the, you know, using love is, I think you're, I think that's awesome. I think it's a great position to have.
此外，这一切都被我们无法见面、互动和联系的事实所加剧。一旦我们，一旦你真正见到某人并与他们联系，倾听他们并听到他们的声音，我认为你所说的一切都是真的。当你能联系甚至触摸某人、拥抱某人、与某人交谈、倾听某人时，这会使它更有价值。这一切都有助于你的观点。而且你一直非常坚定和一致，卫生局局长先生，在这个艰难的时期，成为我们国家那种令人安慰的、非情绪化的、非政治性的常识中心。所以谢谢你，请继续。我喜欢你不断回到，依赖于，你知道，使用爱，我认为你，我认为这太棒了。我认为这是一个很好的立场。
I think that's, it was the great Joe Elliott of the band, Def Leppard, who said, pour some sugar on me. I love that. Dr. Murthy, thank you so much for your time today. We so appreciate you and everything you've done, everything you continue to do to make us safer, to make the world safer. Much love to you and much appreciated. Yes. Well, thank you so much. Hey, at the risk of taking this long, let me just say one last thing on that point we just raised.
我认为那是，是Def Leppard乐队伟大的Joe Elliott说的，“Pour some sugar on me”。我喜欢那个。Murthy医生，非常感谢你今天的时间。我们非常感谢你和你所做的一切，以及你继续做的一切，让我们更安全，让世界更安全。给你很多的爱，非常感谢。是的。嗯，非常感谢。嘿，冒着时间太长的风险，让我最后再说一点关于我们刚才提出的那一点。
About Def Leppard? This is so important. Is it about Def Leppard? Not about Def Leppard, although that was my sixth grade prom dance song. Sure. Sure. Pour some sugar on me. No, but just to say this, this point about love, this is, this to me is a defining question of our time right now.
关于Def Leppard？这太重要了。是关于Def Leppard吗？不是关于Def Leppard，尽管那是我的六年级舞会舞曲。当然。当然。“Pour some sugar on me”。不，只是想说这个，关于爱的这一点，这对我来说是我们这个时代的一个决定性问题。
Fundamentally, I believe that there are two forces ultimately that drive us in our decision making. There's love and there's fear and they have different manifestations, right? Fear can show up as anger, as insecurity, as jealousy, as rage. Yeah, to me, it's the empire and the rebellion from Star Wars, but keep kind. Right. But love can also show up as kindness and generosity and empathy. And in every moment in our life when we're making decisions, whether it's about how we treat a stranger, how we treat the person next to us that we know and our neighbor, our family, we have this choice, you know, how we react to the news, whether we choose to turn on the TV or turn off the TV work.
从根本上说，我相信最终有两种力量驱动我们的决策。有爱，也有恐惧，它们有不同的表现形式，对吧？恐惧可以表现为愤怒、不安全感、嫉妒、狂暴。是的，对我来说，这是《星球大战》中的帝国和叛军，但保持友善。对。但爱也可以表现为善良、慷慨和同理心。在我们生命中的每一刻，当我们做决定时，无论是关于我们如何对待陌生人，我们如何对待身边认识的人和我们的邻居、我们的家人，我们都有这个选择，你知道，我们如何对新闻做出反应，我们是否选择打开电视或关掉电视工作。
We have a choice to make. And what strikes me is that because we each have a choice, we each have power, right? And so if we are looking to build a culture that is rooted in love and not fear, that is a choice we have to ask ourselves how to make each day in the small decisions and in the big decisions. And I started thinking about this five and a half years ago when we found out that we were pregnant with our first child. And I still remember coming home and my wife was sitting at the dining room chair, just actually just a few feet away from here. And she just looked really happy. I was like, what's going on? And she showed me the pregnancy test indicator, which was positive.
我们有一个选择要做。让我印象深刻的是，因为我们每个人都有选择，我们每个人都有力量，对吧？所以如果我们寻求建立一种植根于爱而不是恐惧的文化，那是我们每天在小决定和大决定中必须问自己如何做出的选择。我五年前开始思考这个问题，当时我们发现我们怀上了第一个孩子。我还记得回到家，我妻子坐在餐桌椅上，实际上离这里只有几英尺远。她看起来真的很开心。我问，怎么了？她给我看了验孕棒，是阳性的。
And we were just so thrilled and so excited to be parents. But I remember sitting down on the bed next to her and just pausing for a month, letting it sink in. And there was a part of me which was got anxious and was like, oh my God, like, what kind of world are we bringing our child into? Is this going to be a world where people help our child up when he falls down or is this going to be a hostile, fearful, angry world? And it was in that moment that it really solidified within me that as a parent, my responsibility now was to make sure that the world for my child and for other children was more likely to be grounded in love rather than fear. And that had to be done through the choices that I made in my life, in whatever sphere, my personal life, my work life, etc. And that's why it can in a time when so many people feel disempowered and feel like the problems that we're facing are so big and too big for them to make a difference and on their own. I just want us to never forget that we have the power to choose between love and fear and the ripple effects that we have on other people when we do that.
我们非常激动，非常兴奋能成为父母。但我记得坐在她旁边的床上，停顿了一个月，让它沉淀下来。我有一部分感到焦虑，心想，天哪，我们把我们的孩子带到了一个什么样的世界？这是一个人们在他跌倒时会扶他起来的世界，还是一个充满敌意、恐惧、愤怒的世界？就在那一刻，它在我心中真正巩固了，作为一名父母，我的责任现在是确保我的孩子和其他孩子的世界更有可能建立在爱而不是恐惧的基础上。这必须通过我在生活中做出的选择来完成，无论是在哪个领域，我的个人生活，我的工作生活等等。这就是为什么在一个许多人感到无能为力，觉得我们面临的问题太大，他们自己无法做出改变的时候。我只是希望我们永远不要忘记，我们有权在爱与恐惧之间做出选择，以及当我们这样做时，我们对其他人产生的连锁反应。
Directly, the example we set indirectly for those who may not say anything to us, but are impacted by our example, that is powerful. That is how culture changes. That's how our country will change. That's how we will become better and create a better world for our kids as well. Amen. That's so great. That's fantastic. What a wonderful... Thank you for that. Thank you, Dr. Murphy. That's fantastic. By the way, we should just air that everywhere. Everything you just said. That'll be our little teaser.
直接地，我们间接为那些可能不对我们说什么，但受到我们榜样影响的人树立的榜样，那是强大的。这就是文化改变的方式。这就是我们国家将改变的方式。这就是我们将变得更好，并为我们的孩子创造一个更美好世界的方式。阿门。太棒了。太棒了。多么美妙的……谢谢你。谢谢你，Murphy医生。太棒了。顺便说一句，我们应该到处播放这个。你刚才说的一切。那将是我们的小预告片。
Thank you so much for being here. We appreciate it. Thank you for your time. Thank you for your service. Well, thank you all so much. I really enjoyed talking to you. And I got to say, even when I still had the little cover over my lens, just hearing the love and brotherhood between you guys and the good humor, it made me feel good. Jason, I got to tell you before you leave that couples retreat, watch that movie so many times, loved it, because Derek kept me laughing. Thank you for that. Thank you. That was fun to do. All right. Well, thank you so much. Enjoy the rest of your weekend and we'll see you on the TV.
非常感谢你能来。我们很感激。谢谢你的时间。谢谢你的服务。嗯，非常感谢你们。我真的很喜欢和你们交谈。我必须说，即使当我还在镜头上盖着小盖子时，听到你们之间的爱和兄弟情谊以及良好的幽默感，这让我感觉很好。Jason，在你离开那个夫妻静修处之前，我必须告诉你，看了那部电影很多次，很喜欢它，因为Derek让我一直笑。谢谢你。做那件事很有趣。好的。嗯，非常感谢。享受周末剩下的时间，我们会在电视上见到你。
All right. Take care. All right. Bye-bye, guys. Bye-bye. Bye. Sean, how did that come about? What do you just... You have a number on the White House? I was talking to our producer, Michael Granteri, and we were just coming out and I go, you know, I really want to chat. I love stuff like that. I love jobs that I don't know anything about. I want to learn about. How do you do that? Why do you do that? All that kind of stuff.
好的。保重。好的。再见，伙计们。再见。再见。Sean，那是怎么发生的？你只是……你在白宫有号码吗？我当时正在和我们的制片人Michael Granteri交谈，我们刚出来，我说，你知道，我真的很想聊天。我喜欢那样的东西。我喜欢我不了解的工作。我想了解。你是怎么做到的？你为什么那样做？所有这类事情。
I think it's fascinating. Oh, yeah. I mean, as much as I love all of our super fancy Hollywood friends, it's so nice to have somebody from science or music or art or anything other than Hollywood. And then we get the surge in general for God's sakes. Yeah, I love that. How's it going? Super fun. There's so many other things. I wanted to talk about loneliness, I think, because you did all these studies on it. I think it's fascinating. Yeah.
我觉得这很迷人。哦，是的。我的意思是，尽管我喜欢我们所有超级时髦的好莱坞朋友，但有来自科学、音乐、艺术或好莱坞以外的任何领域的人真是太好了。然后我们得到了卫生局局长，看在上帝的份上。是的，我喜欢那个。进展如何？超级有趣。还有很多其他事情。我想谈谈孤独，我想，因为你做了所有这些关于它的研究。我觉得这很迷人。是的。
But we can do it next time. Yeah, promise. Yeah, promises, promises. Next time what? No, this is your last episode. What are you talking about? This is it. Yeah. You go check your email.
但我们可以下次再做。是的，保证。是的，承诺，承诺。下次什么？不，这是你的最后一集。你在说什么？就是这样。是的。你去查查你的电子邮件。
Okay, great. Let me just check it out. No, but how cool is that? I mean, in a day and an age where people, I love that he said that he never wanted to do that. He never wanted to go to public service. Never thought he could make any difference. That he does it under Obama. He's become a surge in general under Obama. Then we go through four years, challenging years, and he comes back and he says yes to Joe Biden. Biden! Oh, that's a good one, Biden. Great one.
好的，太棒了。让我查一下。不，但这有多酷？我的意思是，在人们的时代，我喜欢他说他从来不想那样做。他从来不想去公共服务。从来没想过他能做出任何改变。他在奥巴马手下做。他在奥巴马手下成为卫生局局长。然后我们经历了四年，充满挑战的四年，他回来了，他对Joe Biden说了是。Biden！哦，那是一个很好的，Biden。很棒的一个。
Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Smart. Last.
Smart。Last。Smart。Last。Smart。Last。Smart。Last。
SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjolf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grant Terry. Smart. Last. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartList是由Rob Armjolf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Grant Terry 100%有机和手工制作的。Smart。Last。我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondry应用程序中的Wondry Plus提前收听且无广告。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。